[Music]
[Applause]
well the fat man up Batman I am Kevin
Smith hey as you can see I'm missing
somebody man Robin or Batman depending
on where your stand is missing mark
right now is at the Castle Rock premiere
at bad robot
so we had already when he realized it
was happening we had already sold a
bunch tickets and stuff so I was like
should i cancel the show or keep going
he City keep going he said but I'm gonna
try to get there at 9:30 so hopefully
Mark's gonna be here like in an hour
fresh off the Castle Rock premiere and
he'll be able to tell us all about that
but don't worry you're not getting
shortchanged it's not just gonna be me
standing up here I did bring a co-host
and I brought somebody who's from the
world legit from genre world also
employed in this business and [ __ ] but
before we go anywhere let me just
[ __ ] point out for the record folks
listening at home or watching at home
don't know this but we started a half an
hour late and this is probably gonna
sound like the most Hollywood [ __ ]
excuse but Quentin Tarantino is at fault
he they shut down Hollywood Boulevard
which has created [ __ ] traffic all
over the place because he's shooting the
Manson movie right down the street so
yeah so if you were sitting there going
what the [ __ ] with traffic that's what
it was I too was like what the [ __ ]
with traffic apparently they've turned a
stretch of Hollywood Boulevard into late
60s Los Angeles Hollywood so when the
show's done here I'm a professional in
the movie industry and I understand like
when we're working when professionals
are working you know of course it
doesn't help to be interrupted and
whatnot so responsive
I should discourage y'all from going to
look as a brother filmmaker but as a
Quentin Tarantino fan like it's
happening a few blocks away so when the
show's over
go [ __ ] and look man like oh my god I
saw Quentin direct up close once on the
set of Jackie Brown years and years and
years ago it was interesting it's tough
but look man they're [ __ ] turn him
back the clock and spending a [ __ ] ton
of money to do so because if you're
shutting down that money blocks and
Hollow Boulevard you've got cash so
that's the only reason that was late
I loved being able to blame it on
another [ __ ] filmmaker but going
forward tonight I do have a co-host he
comes from the world man he's a writer
on Supergirl that's how I met him right
first episode that I ever directed of
Supergirl Supergirl lives he wrote he
co-wrote but he mostly wrote and we were
there in the trenches together he came
up and as I made the whole episode and I
was like look [ __ ] stay the whole
time I've learned to direct I mean
you're learning from me but [ __ ]
still you'll learn something and [ __ ]
we'll go through the whole process
together you could take over sometimes
cuz I'll be baked like it'll be
fantastic and so he came and stayed the
whole [ __ ] time
next time I did Supergirl he wrote on
that script next time as well so I met
and fell in love with him up in
Vancouver he's got a bunch of experience
in the world and he will help me hold
down the fort until mark gets back now
give a warm [ __ ] fat man on Batman
welcome for my co-host tonight Erik
Carrasco lazy Joe
[Applause]
hey everybody what's this is Eric man
Eric tell him how long you've been
working on Supergirl until give me a
bona fides oh is my third year on
Supergirl
we're going into season four right now
so I've been on since season two when
you first directed right yeah this year
before that basically nothing this is my
first big job is it really yeah I did of
course I told him you had a lot of
[ __ ] bona fides I did a cartoon for
Netflix called legend quest okay
possibly maybe one of you is watched it
that's like the most you'll ever get you
heard all the work that's it the four
legend quest and I did a little bit of
Justice League action on Cartoon Network
that was the DC Comics connection did
you do what was the Star Wars short film
you were involved with oh is Hoshino was
a Star Wars just our short that we did
yeah it's got an icon in it okay so now
you've been working on Supergirl for a
chunk of time Erik is their in-house
comic book eric knows a lot about the
world the source material and stuff so
almost all of the Legion of super-heroes
stuff that was Slick Rick over here man
he's the guy that like if you hear any
references or deep cuts or connections
comic books usually it's coming out of
him how many people in the writers room
describe the writers room on Supergirl
about 10 people in the writers room
that's right how many episodes right 22
episodes 23 last year 22 this year and
we yeah we metal our way through and I
actually started giving out prizes when
people spot the Easter eggs now because
I get so excited when people actually
notice the Legion of super-heroes stuff
or the specific issue references we
stick in there so I saw somebody on
Twitter at San Diego comic-con this year
at the Supergirl panel cosplay Dazz
drunk Lena Luthor from Cara so it was a
specific is the first time anybody's
ever cosplay tis a specific line of
dialogue that I wrote was from a scene
where she like smashes a wine glass and
she's drunk and Cara comes in
she smashes a glass and says look I made
a metaphor and somebody called that out
like and then asked a question at the
supergirl panel at comic-con and I was
like crazy yeah you know Luthor's been
kill almost killed 11 times on the show
in assassination attempts when is she
getting a bodyguard that was the that
was the question she asked so her
cosplay was so [ __ ] specific to
something that yeah you wrote yeah
that's crazy
that's like me sing Silent Bob cosplay
or something like that you're like I
wrote and created drunk Lena Lena
specifically I wrote and create I did
not play her so it's a little different
oh man kind of jumped in and
understudied what is alright so how many
so how many episodes do you as a staff
writer get to write all those shows are
co-written so there's at least two
writers on every script and I've done
nine now I just finished my first one of
season four so yeah you're doing about
four your names on for a year so but you
know there was a trailer for that they
dropped at Comic Con which is a lot of
footage mostly from like last season and
stuff but the tail end of last season we
saw a setup for what was essentially the
female version of red Sun Marc Miller's
very famous Superman storyline that
tells a story about what would have
happened if the rocket from Krypton
landed in Russia instead of the United
States fantastic [ __ ] great comic
Elseworlds
miniseries one shot came member if it
was more than one bless you many I think
so now that it looks like they're doing
well that's what it looked like the tail
end of last season like the very button
like this took place in Russia and it
kind of seemed like it is that yeah
alright hundred percent but we said that
I can say that because yeah yeah it'll
be read daughter I guess instead of red
Sun but but yeah that's what we're doing
is that the main storyline no there's
more they've announced are kind of big
bad this year is agent Liberty from the
comics
Jurgens character yeah so everybody
there's a lot more going on in the
season than just the read daughter thing
but we will and everybody knows already
the Big Bad is gonna be Age of Liberty
yeah they announced that Sam Witwer is
playing did they do that last year Darth
Maul really oh the boys are north and
yeah Darth Maul and solo and in rebels
and in Clone Wars and then and oh my god
did they announce last season who the
big bad was gonna be yeah cuz it brought
out odet yeah for a game so I guess they
have to in advance did a bit of press
all right man the we got a professional
with us and we've got a [ __ ] ton of news
to get through because Comic Con just
ended fairly recently before we dive
into that I also wanted to thank the
good folks at Comic Con International
Eddie Abraham particularly I when I went
to do my Hall H panel like every year
Eddie goes to introduce me first he gets
up and he's like there's gonna be
cursing you know just to let the
audience know and [ __ ] and then
everybody gets up and leaves with their
kid so he got up and he introduced me
and then as I want to leave you hung out
a little longer and then he started
talking and saying nice things about me
and I was like oh [ __ ] I'm about to get
whacked like yeah and then he kind of he
said so because of that you're we're
giving you an inkpot award the inkpot
award for those don't know what it is is
an award that the cine are coming but
Comic Cons been giving out since 1974 if
you look at the list of folks that win
it's for folks that you know you have
given something a pop culture or
something like that if you look at the
list
it's an incredible who's who of everyone
I grew up idolizing and you know I knew
this award existed but I always figured
like alright man one day when if you get
to be like Stan's age and you're still
around the [ __ ] comic-con they might
toss one of these your way turns out I
nearly had to die that's it and
so they were like we better give him one
[ __ ] fast but it was so incredibly
moving like I legit wanted this and I
said it like on babble I said it in a
tweet as well and then some people like
kind of kicked back at it going yeah
right
but it's so [ __ ] true winning that
award meant more to me than like winning
an Oscar winning an Oscar is like I know
I'm supposed to be a filmmaker that's
like how I got introduced and whatnot
but I don't like that's just one thing I
do so I don't really consider myself
that 100% of the time and I also have
never really tried to excel in that
field but I I I like being in the world
of celebrating popular culture this show
is that I don't sit on this show and
talk about like my stuff I really sit on
this show and fan out about other stuff
and whatnot so I don't know for me it
felt like I was getting the award from a
community that I do feel deeply [ __ ]
connected to as opposed to one where
I've always felt on the outside of
manners is really [ __ ] sweet but now
that I have nothing to shoot for
whatsoever
yeah that's maybe that's why they gave
it to me like would you please stop here
now you just have to win it like a
[ __ ] Oscar or something no [ __ ] that
you must be given out retro actively if
they ever decide one day you know what
we were wrong toss deserves an A special
I wouldn't [ __ ] show up at a dog's I
drug it be like so apologetic at the
Shirley Temple special Oscar it's a
little warm yeah I would want rescue us
guard up and [ __ ] stitched but yeah so
it was really wonderful of a man that
made my comic-con I was I was I had this
I used to love doing Hall H back in the
day and because I so much my identity
was tied up and it was a dangerous thing
because one year nobody was in Hall H
Star Wars no star course this year so
you had like Christ doors everybody was
there so the year that they sucked
star wars sucked the crowd out man like
I definitely learned like oh [ __ ]
this is not this doesn't dictate your
worth like you know I was always scared
like what if I go out there and nobody's
in the audience I won't be relevant
anymore and then I did go out there and
I learned very quick that [ __ ] it people
like look we like you but we love Star
Wars and so off they went so ever since
then I've had like a real touch-and-go
relationship with with it I still I did
it the year after I didn't do it last
year but then I was scheduled to do it
this year and you know I was kind of it
was something that all weekend long I
was on the IMD boat interviewing people
and stuff so and I chose at night so I
was like working all weekend and that
was the one aspect of the weekend I was
kind of least looking forward to because
it's a big [ __ ] room and it's like I
can't pull [ __ ] I used to be 6,000
somebody said this year it's 8,500 I'm
like jesus [ __ ] christ with no Marvel
here are you crazy
and and so I was like not looking
forward to it
and that folks were sweet man they
[ __ ] showed up and packed the [ __ ]
room for my whole age thing this year
and I'm sure a lot of it was like oh
look he didn't die but regardless it was
[ __ ] really nice I don't care if they
were there for the Freak value of like
he's still a lot or if they just come
and they had come and hung out and it
was really [ __ ] sweet man so I don't
know it was a wonderful way to end a
very busy comic-con which has yielded a
[ __ ] ton of news which I guess you have
aggregated for us I have googled yes oh
my god mark barnard taught you his
secret skills the Google food all right
folks
we are about to dive into the first
section of fat men on Batman and that's
always the news and Eric Carrasco here
has went and dug up some [ __ ] news
give it up for Eric the news how
it was hard it was really hard I've got
a hole folded up piece of paper you know
look how much homework I do it is a
little ratty folded up put in my back
pocket all the news that fits I guess
you want to go movies first you want to
go TV first you want to actually do some
comics first what you want fired your
dealer's choice
talk about Comic Con okay area around it
this thing you'll like did you hear
about the Marvel experience a Marvel
trauma center at Comic Con by Petco Park
okay
here buy this no they ran it there was
no Marvel it was kind of a weird calm
because there was no Marvel there there
was no Game of Thrones there there was
no stranger things there are a lot of
the usual suspects kind of in Star Wars
really so the only big Marvel presence
aside from animation and some of the TV
stuff was this trauma center they set up
so that people who were quote
traumatized by infinity War part 1 and
all the people who come and get some
[ __ ] hugs and they literally had like
counselors up and front people out in
seats and stuff and somebody would be
like so what are your best Marvel
memories what are your favorite lines of
dialogue who are you saddest about
leaving us the depart it was like a
leftovers episode about infinity War
part 1 what who paid for this it's
marble was like an official Marvel thing
you got like a shirt and the doughnut at
the end and they were like they were
like here you go something feel better
yeah it's like here eat a doughnut
that's happiness and then they sent you
outside there was like a photo op with a
giant Incredible Hulk and you could come
inside his warm embrace and get a hug
from the Hulk so you probably saw like
it's people hashtag did and stuff and
you can find like photos of people just
getting a hug from a giant oh [ __ ] on
their way out it was just really like
sweet that is what they call now Comic
Con and activation and activation an
off-site activation it was off-site so
that means alright so it's an off-site
activation with none of the expensive
cast not a Malia tag yeah I think mobile
anybody ever is gonna be like [ __ ] Chris
Evans man
we're gonna hire a local the hugs of
week we still got press and all we had
to do is pay for a dozen donuts every
genius idea man that's really [ __ ]
smart it's one of those things you want
to find out whose idea was that and
sight the mouth yeah somebody so he gets
a day off or something for that one but
it was a very Marvel like con other than
the banners that hung up on the the
lamppost celebrating 10 years of Marvel
movies it was you know you guys are
gonna see they're like as we go through
the news there's a [ __ ] ton of DC stuff
and it's not because I'm a corporate
shill it's because they just they
announce more [ __ ] like is that is there
a d23 coming up is that why they're
holding they're waiting like [ __ ] Comic
Con we got our own cuz every year they
put more stuff into the d23 so people
come to that other off-site [ __ ] you I
did the the good place experience you
watch the good place I have not watched
it my wife watched it and explained it
to me it's a great [ __ ] show yeah the
concept that I did not think would work
and they did a really really involved
installation where you come in and you
basically enter a room with a video from
Ted Danson and some of they only did
like a comic-con specific little mini
good place episode and they send you
into a town square it was really cute
actors and like they're like you you
were not supposed to be here in the good
place and then eventually they freaked
out and chase you out and they're like
you should go to the bad place and they
do a whole thing in that show how many
people here watch the good place throw
your hands together in that show is it
have a is there it was there twist at
the end of the season one spoiling it I
mean did you just spoil it
I just spoiled it I don't know no that's
good no we didn't spoil it at all well
there is a twist and you should watch it
did it then change season 2 yeah I have
this show I think more than any other
has this incredible ability to like
every episode you think they've run out
of story every single episode they'll
like push the whole paradigm of the show
and be like okay I don't know how
they're getting out of this one I don't
know how they're gonna do another
episode after this like it's done now
it's done now they've done all the show
they can do and then they do another
episode and they keep finding ways to
like write themselves into these
incredibly deep holes and then come out
of it somehow so who created the show
and make sure who's the Parks and Rec
guy it's my office yeah and then what
season two at this point uh to be coming
into season three and when they start up
again I'm sorry yeah you wanna do some I
guess we can do our news since I'm here
okay well got some press super got some
press today after Comic Con you see
there's Shane Black hey yes we're Shane
Black was like I would direct an episode
of Supergirl or it's coming for your
turf I know I'm like [ __ ] off man like
you got Iron Man chuckles look Shane
Black's an amazing [ __ ] director and
writer and stuff I got to interview him
on the boat this year right to tell him
yeah for the the predator I got to tell
him and I was like there was this when I
was a kid I saw this 20/20 piece about
him as a writer because he was a spec
script seller he had written me a
there's a period where everyone was spec
script crazy you can write a scrip have
a bunch of Studios bid for it the bid
would go up to like three million four
million or something like that and so he
was a rock star writer of sorts and so
they 2020 like followed him around while
they were making the last Boy Scout
while they were on set there and I
remember I was the first time anyone had
ever like lionized a writer the rumor
that had always come out or the joke
you'd always heard is like nobody gave a
[ __ ] about the writer and the movie
business and yet here was this kind of
young kid who was like commanding
respect huge [ __ ] business and stuff
and he was being cited as as the sexy
not because like he's in front of the
camera but because he's behind the
camera so to me as a person who was like
in two words at that point I was a go
[ __ ] that gives me hope so I got to tell
him that and stuff so if he wanted to do
those of course if I already told him
yes on Twitter yes cheating [ __ ] Joanne
you [ __ ]
um yeah oh my god snap him up a good
[ __ ] luck that just seems like
something nice you can see the
interviewer go frosty from Collider you
see the interview go like that is not
what I expected you to say I said could
you guess direct on anything and you
said yeah Supergirl he threw that out
there it was it was kind of a little bit
of a backhanded think it was like you
know you don't wanna go on like homeland
has like a really really defined style
maybe want to do like Supergirl and then
he goes like you know I was in a hotel
room at some point and I just turned on
Supergirl and all of a sudden I found
myself watching two seasons of Supergirl
straight through from beginning to end
so I guess Supergirl and the interviewer
just kind of like takes it being goes
how what I expected you to say that dude
did Kiss Kiss Bang Bang was one of the
best films ever spent in my life so my
god give him super girl give him every
CW movie if he wants to take a crack at
it
it's fiction and we also have anything
about the predator like good or bad I
heard that they they screen some footage
at the at Comic Con and apparently some
roided out like a mega predator comes
and kills a smaller predator he predates
the predator and that's like rips its
head off with the spine shared by the
predator this time we've got a bigger
predator yeah Shane who Shane was
literally like you wanted more of that
we figured that like the first couple
movies the Predators kept losing to
humans and then they would like come
back to the planet and admit defeat and
so other predators would start writing
up and be like we're gonna go back there
where win this time so now that's what
they're doing that's the idea there's a
whole predator culture you don't know
about so we're gonna learn about that in
the predator that was the big news that
was covered by you know all over the
place mainstream outlets and stuff was
we're doing the first transgender
superhero on television or anywhere
really and yeah
Nicolle mains is playing her is
character a blender out to the san diego
smashes on the pan around she was on the
boat with us as well
who is she playing she's playing me an
all-new character this season right got
some connections to a dream girl from
the legion of super-heroes and she's
gonna be the superhero dreamer really
yeah that's awesome this year seems to
be about vigilantes that was what they
threw out in the trailer
yeah that I saw Wow when did that when
did you know that was happening we right
at the start of a season so if we went
in knowing knowing we were gonna cast
this part when and knowing we were gonna
rake to this part and we were working
according always been incredibly
progressive and diverse as well so it
makes absolute [ __ ] sense
that's huge yeah so what is what do you
how does one go about writing that was
an experience none of us were familiar
with so we had some some folks in glad
this guy Nick from glad came in and you
know we've had people come and visit the
office and talk about their experiences
some activists Nicole herself is an
activist right I think she's done I
think she's done other stuff before um
not a ton but she's amazing and she's
gonna be so good I look forward to that
I go up to Supergirl
when is it I'm doing episode 4 I'm doing
I'm doing an episode I shouldn't say
which one exactly have announced yet and
I could still get fired if they dig
through my tweet
what is one is that when it is September
or something isn't like that I don't
remember the date I probably should have
looked up the day before
it'll be fun now look forward to be my
first time back on my 4th Supergirl
episode yeah good time all right what
else your girl danielle panabaker is
directing a flash yes danielle who plays
Caitlin killer frost Caitlin snow is
going to direct and she's the first I
think the first actress in the CW
universe
yeah or in the Berlanti verse or in
arrow at least any shows yeah to make
the move to directing some of the actors
have Tom Cavanagh has directed a couple
episodes for flash but why not why not
Daniel she's been around oh like since
she was a kid on sets actors and
actresses make amazing first-time
directors but you know they always hit
the ground running because they've
aggregated a style you sit behind enough
directors over the course of your career
you're gonna sit there and go like I
would do that I wouldn't do that I would
change this and stuff so you're gonna
have it take that's why actors tend to
make the crossover very well so I'm sure
she'll do fantastic when you were on set
was she like asking you [ __ ] like
watching from behind the camera and like
she if she wanted to learn anything
no she wasn't asking man we sit around
chitchat and stuff but I remember at one
point having a conversation with her
about Lexie directing Lexie it was a
script supervisor on flash for a while
and then she became a director and she
should have been directing forever
because nobody knew the show like she
did right so Tom had directed and we
were all sitting around I guess on and
I'm on a set at one point and I was just
saying like the general you should all
[ __ ] take advantage of that like you
should all direct while you're here
you'll never find a safer more welcoming
environment than the people that you
work with every week nobody here wants
you to fail everyone here wants you to
succeed and stuff so like all these
before you leave the show before the
show ends put in your bid like Tom try
to direct an episode and stuff so I am
she did this no she's I'm sure she was
working on this for a long long time I
think she shadowed somebody last year
yeah when you do one of these you got a
shadow somebody there's like a directing
program remember correctly I think she
did I think she shadowed Lexi but she's
been working toward this for a bit now
that's been huge what they don't want is
like one of us to just be like anyway
I'm directing one now like they want
people who care about it and who have
learned about it and who know their [ __ ]
so I wonder if they'll give her a
Caitlyn heavy episode or will it be
Kaitlyn light for a first time director
I imagine they'll be like look she can't
[ __ ] wear that many hats we'll
probably
Caitlyn goes away this episode comes
back at the end like what did I miss
other TV news oh uh Clone Wars is coming
back it was a 10th anniversary the Clone
Wars at Comic Con and they went through
and did a panel they did a reunion panel
they brought back a bunch of people and
Dave Filoni threw up a trailer and was
like we're doing more of that that [ __ ]
you like has come back in style people
went crazy [ __ ] bananas they never
finished the story was a little
unfinished it kind of was like and I so
goes off doing something and what if
they just move on to rebels yeah it was
a there's a gap between them and they
moved on to rebels but apparently
they're going back and finishing Clone
Wars with another tour of duty and it
seemed like 12 episodes next year so
that was like shockingly some of the
like they kept that under wraps I yeah
very quiet I talked about on Babylon I
might have talked about on Fatman last
week I think this is their backdoor way
of bringing ahsoka into live-action yeah
cuz it's a female character that you
know it's strong and there's a base that
knows the character and Craig's work
yeah big support for the character huge
fandom why not cross her over there's
there very few Princess Leia stories
they could do anymore they're never
gonna recast that part so you know
Princess Leia is more legacy character
at this point with ahsoka you can bring
in somebody and you tell new stories
she's a for some period of time between
Clone Wars and rebels it's also gonna be
on the Disney platform so I think it's
gonna their streaming service is gonna
help launch that and get that going so
she's also just a visually interesting
character general which is something
that you know the Star Wars always
benefits when a character always
benefits in Star Wars when they're you
know oh look at that they look [ __ ]
cool and stuff but she would be more of
a blend than than we were used to when
they go alien they usually go full alien
and the humans look human and she's kind
of very humanoid but she's like yeah
yeah
while we're on Disney you see the iron
fist stuff the iron fist trailer for
season 2 looks I thank God Mark's not
here
I think it looks great like I thought it
really looked great man I heard a story
or read something about the cat that did
season 2 is a different person
altogether
yeah Bravin what is it raven Messer yeah
he didn't do it apparently or Shila is
that a man or a woman raven now he
didn't do it first season yeah I knew
this season and apparently it's like
great so yeah I worked with him on
Sleepy Hollow and he talked to me at one
point about like let's get in and do a
big focus on the choreography and make
it like good kung-fu movie [ __ ] yeah
which you kind of want for iron yeah
that was the you know a thing a lot of
people had complaints about in season
one was like it's iron fist man it's
gonna look amazing the fights are gonna
fight suck
and and you know when Daredevils fights
are beating your fights like you know
you might want to read this guy's blind
so we're gonna we're all getting iron
fist - the second time and this time
we're gonna [ __ ] enjoy it yeah put me
in charge of Mario yeah oh yeah it's do
it get him the tagline we got a Buffy
reboot coming people like Buffy the
Vampire Slayer
it's from Joss Whedon so we don't have
to worry about like is this kind is this
canonical is this the right [ __ ] Joss
Whedon and showrunner Monica was of
green who's the [ __ ] amazing writer
did alias and lost and fringe
created midnight Texas and yeah I don't
know how far along they are it seems
like they don't even necessarily have a
script yet
no one's cast yet I don't even think
they have a network yet but that's
coming soon and they kind of announced
that during Comic Con you were a Buffy
kid is a huge Buffy kid and in writers
world they still use in writers rooms
they still use Buffy terminology and
stuff they had all this stuff like if
you're just looking for like the random
science thing or magic thing that you're
dealing with this episode they called it
like phlebotomy and so we'll just say
like yeah and then they get the right
still use it's also big bad is a term
that comes yeah I used it I literally
use it at the beginning of this yeah
yeah so as a fan when you hear a it's
coming back where where do you stand
I'm stoked but I also don't know exactly
what they're doing with it they said
reboot which makes it sound like Buffy
herself is coming back oh is that right
they said they said they said with a
black lead but they didn't say like a
black lead who is playing Buffy or not
so there is a world where it's kind of a
sequel show there is also a world where
Buffy is remake is Giles to some degree
or something like that dude a Creed with
it like where she's the teacher and
she's got to teach the next Slayer or
something like that do the Cobra Kai
Buffy version yes all right well I mean
not a lot of information on that and
then we got oh [ __ ] there's so much more
DC stuff Geoff Johns announced he's
writing star girl writing an e executive
producing a 13-episode season of star
girl there's one of my favorite
characters up ie
probably yeah I think it is T and he's
doing which now takes his total to like
16 shows or something Berlanti did
Titans as well right thank you troll
Batman show yeah
yeah the forthcoming Doom Patrol did
they show anything from that no they
didn't shout anything no all right so
this is the first Batman on Batman show
where we got to say [ __ ] Batman no I
think we've said it before particularly
during the age of a flexure write your
headlines
Kevin Smith says [ __ ] batfleck no that
was you
okay so star girl on the DC Universe app
first off this app of course down like a
evil murderous clown to buy this app
it's like 75 bucks a year so I'm in to
begin with so they don't have to try to
win me that being said I'm happy he's
getting to do the series it has a tied
to his sister if I remember one of the
episodes very very personal care very
personal character for him so that's
cool but you know poor Jeff's been in a
untenable position for a long time as
the guy they put in charge of those DC
movies and he's kind of hamstrung from
getting anything done you know that
looked like the comics within the Snyder
stuff it seemed like but they you know
kind of showed him the door or he took a
producing deal or whatever so he's not
doing that anymore
just as it looks like DC has found its
footing cinematically like obviously
Wonder Woman was a triumph last year but
the two big [ __ ] trailers that came
out of Comic Con are both DC Warner
Brothers movies Aquaman looks [ __ ]
phenomenal really - absolutely
phenomenal and Shazam looks [ __ ] it's
fun it might accidentally induce a child
to enjoy a comic book again like oh it's
[ __ ] crazy so they might have
actually found their footing and and you
know the bolt all three of those movies
have distinct Jeff fingerprints on them
and now he's not gonna be there in the
job to enjoy the spoils of victory but I
sense he's a writer first and foremost
and being able to go create a show
Stargirl probably you know who is good
for him good for his soul good to be
making something as opposed to like you
know trying to trying to be like don't
do that oh they did it you know it seems
like the character that was most
important to him and now he's got 13
episodes to do it seems like he's doing
it all himself I don't know if he'll
hire a staff or what but seems right all
the others just doing it I would be
surprised if you wrote all the episodes
considering like his output as a comic
book writer was insane he was writing a
couple monthly books at one point so
certainly what do they call that when
you write a lot four digits no what's
the word prolific thank you I spoke that
word of what ditches he's certainly
prolific he could actually watch him
write his own [ __ ] his own CEO every
episode of that series yeah I'm before
does anybody do that yeah yeah so we're
gonna we had a little bit that we had a
little bit more DC news Lobo is coming
to Krypton are you [ __ ] sure they're
doing the main man four years I've
waited for a movie and the first one's
gonna get it is [ __ ] on yeah so he's
part of that universe package of
characters yeah Wow
believe me I tried to get him for
Supergirl but Krypton you would imagine
that like if the the beauty of the
Supergirl world license that they've got
for the TV show is it does give them
access to Superman's toy chest
yeah they share a lot of the same
characters but this one for some reason
they wouldn't let you guys do
I don't yeah cuz I there was a rumored
movie and there was I'm sure that's
somewhere and then there's and then
there's this maybe Krypton was just dibs
right away I just I'm certainly in the
no disrespect to Krypton but I I assumed
the first place we'd ever see him would
be in a movie but to afford his space
motorcycle yeah
oh alright well [ __ ] that puts
Krypton they had they tried to get me
with Brainiac and I almost watched it
but I got busy he looked good yeah he
does and now they might get me with
Lobos that a season 2 thing yeah yeah
yeah when it comes back at about
Nightwing and flame bird doing
Kryptonian mythological [ __ ] and it'll
also have Lobo doing biker let's give
him credit man I remember when they
first announced the show's like
Superman's grandpa [ __ ] this [ __ ]
but they're fun in the wedding Adam
Strange yes I inclusion of Adam Strange
really made me go like Jesus that's a
clever idea so it looks like they're
playing with a lot of the toys and one I
would be surprised they get to Legion as
well
yeah they got to be able to play those
still watching The Walking Dead
Andrew Lincoln is leaving the walking
dead over this season and so he gave
like a whole statement in there or Hall
H panel it was like it's gonna be my
last season playing Rick Grimes and I
love the show when this season's the
[ __ ] best
I believe hall age gave him a standing
over his very yeah it was ten years
three leaves on this show is he really
nine seasons ten years such a good guy
really good dude man and he stays in
character I was down there shooting like
wrap arounds for some horror weekend or
something like that [ __ ] so hot
that's all I remember is like how do you
[ __ ] people work in this and everyone
you know between was like being
themselves and [ __ ] and then I went to
talk to him and he was he stayed in
America
Rick with the American accent and I was
like you don't you know I thought he was
doing it for me and I'm like I know dude
like and he was just like you don't want
to spoil it for a young child for you to
preserve the illusion you're not Santa
you know what he said no it's easier for
me to kind of stay in the [ __ ] zone
yes he said part of me will always be a
zombie slayer from England I wonder if
he steps away for a time but then comes
back because it's deep in his DNA at
this point Robert Kirkman said some
really nice things about him and we I
interviewed him for the IMDB before
Comic Con began and he talked about I
think he was the first one he brought
the exclusive to say yeah
andrew is gonna leave and he said
something really nice about like this
guy's my friend man he's been sweating
his balls off in Georgia for the last
like seven eight years and [ __ ] away
from his family like of course I want
him on the show of course he's Rick but
you know I'd like to see him be happy on
a personal level as well so that's huge
I never imagined you see The Walking
Dead without Rick yeah yeah but you know
there's they've got 112 characters right
behind them so that means everyone I bet
you everyone's breathing a sigh of
relief to look oh that means I'm not
dying this year
they need the rest of them star trek we
got we have Captain Pike from the
original series and also the movies who
came in at the end of last season so
Star Trek released on the TV show on the
TV show Anson Mount playing Captain Pike
came in at the end of last season this
season they released kind of a trailer
of footage from it looks a lot more like
the 2009 Star Trek has a lot of the
action that people watching discovery in
the first season
we're like did a Star Trek is thoughtful
Star Trek is not fun and action-packed
and this is action but it looks like
there's [ __ ] spaceships spinning
around and like jokes and stuff so wait
what was first season two thoughtful or
somewhere in between
I think not as thoughtful very action
yet it still had a lot of action it
still kind of looked like the
abrams verse movies 2009 Star Trek but
it had a lot of like slower moments and
pull back fewer jokes this looks like
they're kind of embracing the kind of
fun of it a little bit more that Alex
Kurtzman so go getting further away from
classic Star Trek see how we'll see how
Trek fans feel about they are bringing
in Spock so at some point what yeah that
was announced a while ago but then they
haven't cast anybody for it's not gonna
be kiddo
I don't think so but at some point in
the trailer they say like Spock is away
and we don't know where he is and we're
trying to find him so because that show
takes place like a minute before Star
Trek out or something Mike's pretty
young in itself that's right oh my god
alright well that makes it well you know
I watched the first two or three
episodes of that streaming series and
the one thing I walked away with is like
man that makeup is complex okay the
Klingon Megan laces can barely move on I
couldn't get paid I couldn't get into
the the plot very deeply cuz I would
just sit there and be like what time do
you have to wake up and get in the
trailer for that kind of [ __ ] makeup
so I might I might jump on this season I
bought the app I got the app I just
never was
you have the app so God's sake man watch
the show right big movie news this I
think this broke right after comic-con
leave the day after Comicon Robert
DeNiro in negotiations for the Joker
movie wow man this is the Todd Phillips
then say they said some sort of TV
personality oh I did read about this
he's yeah he's playing a like a talk
show host or TV personality who has
helped shape the Joker's personality or
something like that so I don't know if
this is a good I don't know what type of
TV personality but maybe somebody [ __ ]
up I assumed it was the Scorsese
connection that brought that into being
gotta be they've got him they've added
what's her name Frances McDorman hmm is
playing the Joker's mother and of course
they've got Joaquin Phoenix Phoenix
Phoenix
[Music]
Joaquin Phoenix has lady heinous yes who
did they just say they was the girl who
played Domino yes he was it beats I
think she's been added to the cast yep
so yeah they're going they're moving
they are they they have a release date
ooh it's enduring awards season in 2019
I heard it's a really good script so
yeah we'll see how it goes
I'm telling you man once again harking
them back to that [ __ ] Aquaman
trailer it looks so [ __ ] fun that
look like what guardians did for space
that's what Aquaman does for the ocean
yeah it just creates a well then the
oceans and the desert when he jumps out
into it at the end they're like he's not
just in the water yeah that's his
kryptonite it does it looks [ __ ]
phenomenal looks like it's got a bit of
Game of Thrones to it looks like he's
got a bit of Black Panther to it looks
like they were making it they were like
what do people like and they just put
all that [ __ ] I mean there is a
straight-up like Wakanda shot in it
where they like emerge into it latest
all that's missing is her going like we
hide this with technology exactly but
hey man steal from the good ones
you might have something like James
Bond's great yeah and the [ __ ]
armored sharks look amazing the scene in
the trailer the sequence with young
Arthur with a [ __ ] fish like all
starts staring Adam and [ __ ]
I know the fish are a little CG heavy
but like my god yeah very I mean they
look like more like Nemo than anything
else and [ __ ]
but that was a cool last moment of just
like oh that's [ __ ] metal although
like don't sharks like don't they tell
you like if a shark is attaching you to
punch them in the nose and then they
just [ __ ] Ram the glass with their
lows and I'm like I think this would
injure the sharks was my first eyes
watching this cool trailer I was like
taken out of that what's gonna happen at
[ __ ] short hours and they're gone
good [ __ ] maneater care who you're
[ __ ] friends with people found that on
the Aquaman poster they'd use just like
a Getty Images shot what do you like
search shark Getty Images it just put it
on the poster as one of the sharks
yeah the poster seemed a little bit
rushed my look I give a [ __ ] about it
being a Getty shark but and for your
money why don't they why did they shoot
him like not underwater he looks like he
was shot with like [ __ ] wind blowing
through his hair yeah and then they
surrounded him with fish and why not
just put him in a [ __ ] pool and take
the picture although like the rest of it
looks like hilariously expensive cuz
like their hair is always moving like
that can't be cheap but they were like
we spent all the money on the movie so
here's three dollars for the poster
shoot please make it work there I didn't
go of course but I heard that they're
you know [ __ ] presentation in the
whole age was just oh yeah and they had
like big ass video screen pouring water
and Momoa comes out there was a whole
like setup for you to take a picture
with his Trident and a be like a Black
Manta life-size like thing coming at you
like on the floor that that was the
other thing in the tournament had they
showed us the trailer the day before it
dropped because James Wan was on the
boat being interviewed and he was gonna
do and did a commentary track for the
trailer that's up on IMDB
so we got to see the true
and seeing Black Manta depicted as Black
Manta was breathtaking I assumed you
know they'd they'd be suggestive like
all of the black costume with red eyes
but nobody's gonna do that goofy giant
head yeah the head that looks like
Stewie from Family and [ __ ] man all
sudden were playing the trailer and you
see [ __ ] black mantas practically
step out of the Super Friends and [ __ ]
and I was like ha ha ha like I screamed
real loud and [ __ ] was my biggest
reaction trailer it was black mantas oh
my god and it's not even like he's the
main character he's just some other [ __ ]
that's going on and they said they're
gonna use him in all the movies he'll
always be like a background and she has
spoilers so looks like Patrick Wilson's
the bad guy in this warm ocean mass yeah
James Wan was I get my huge [ __ ] hug
didn't let him go where I was like oh my
god you did the Lord's work it was like
this is [ __ ] phenomenal you gave the
[ __ ] king of the seven seas his
dignity back and [ __ ] like that
I asked him I'd like on Thursday of
comic-con they start you start seeing
first the lego build of Aquaman and then
some of the action figures and the dolls
that they put out in pre-release and
stuff he's got a version of the orange
shirt and the only Aquaman we've seen in
many of these movies so far is is
practically bare chested or armored and
[ __ ]
but he's got the orange [ __ ] shirt so
you know I was talking to James Wan I
was like man the orange [ __ ] shirt
goddamn [ __ ] Black Manta like ocean
masters helmet looks like ocean masters
helmet like like I thank you for keeping
it close why though and how were you
able to make it work and he goes the the
designs aren't broken they're beautiful
so we just leaned into him and stuff if
anything we try to explain more things
like he's like worms or misnamed Oram
and the comics his other name is ocean
master is a supervillain name and he's
like and we found a way to make ocean
master work and I was like we found a
way to make this work
so for him it was like not like these
are logical
things to be like [ __ ] puzzles to be
figured out but he's like there are so
many cool elements you don't want to
[ __ ] throw out let's make it make
sense in this world instead so the movie
seems like it was [ __ ] made with love
man and then the Shazam trailer like I
did not know they were making big with
superheroes it's really really does look
like it - like it's like air it is like
and you know I remember when I first saw
the picture it was Zachary Levi right
we're in the suit you know and I was
like oh [ __ ] they're ruined
you know from what like and in the world
at the picture somebody took but man I
[ __ ] plays like the suit totally yeah
when it's lit it works a lot better than
when it's like a it's got a hoody on it
- like the Shazam version in the comics
yeah although it's like because he kind
of does look even in the movie looks a
little like plasticy you know that way
but in a very intentional lifelike way
like it was with a kid it's almost like
his action figure coming to life and
good jingle all the way sort of dr.
Silvana is the villain I guess yeah
seems like yeah man that even that looks
good it looks like they're on [ __ ]
firm ground yeah happy for them you know
game it's a Wonder Woman footage - yeah
they didn't put that on patty Jenkins
that's not online yet but patty Jenkins
see a sequel footage from Wonder Woman
1984 anybody describe it yeah it's the
it's it's a seems like a really great
mall rat sequel she's in a mall she
takes care of a couple of bad guys and
the mall strings him up saves a kid for
pretzels and she's like an 80s style
mall which if you saw that stranger
things trailer 80s malls are in right
now that's right that's the yeah it's
the new stranger things tease they did
the same thing well he's mall with a
Waldenbooks and stuff they did a really
genius
spot with it because I remember when
they used to do mall commercials when
malls would open up and it was very much
like that [ __ ] commercial alright
what so what they didn't show any
cheetah
I don't think so didn't seem like a way
to roll yeah they did where why Steve
Trevor's back either
I'm hoping it's mark guessed that he's
the Martian Manhunter
oh yeah I remember eliciting that one
yeah you think chief they do cheat it
with a costume or do they do Cheeta as a
mutant I think they'll do Cheeta as a
costume oh my god could you imagine
always save mutant for next movie like
or you could do both like you know if
she's all nutty and puts on the costume
I first started drugging up and [ __ ]
like that seeing anyone in that costume
is gonna be [ __ ] amazing if they can
pull it off like when you look at the
cartoon it kind of works but when you
try to imagine anyone let alone Kristen
Wiig wearing a [ __ ] furry costume so
it do it oh my god I have I believe but
if anyone can pull it off patty Jenkins
called James wad this stuff isn't broke
let's get the actual furry costume yeah
man they're there they seem to be
[ __ ] doing quite well right now you
know they're taking some heat for the
Joker movie but that'll pass as well no
words on Batman though huh
yeah you know nothing on the Matt Reeves
front and at all interesting yeah it's
nice that they're not notably absent
yeah nice that they're not sitting there
going like oh we got we need Batman
they're like look we got I forgot we had
all these other characters and that
seems like they're starting to play with
them yeah good idea we also got trailers
for Godzilla king of the monsters saw
that [ __ ] trailer oh my god it's
classy as lean so hard into like not
like ooh scary monsters like a look at
the Wonder of these things and here's a
straw opening her wing what are they
calling them the Titans yeah because I
think they got tired of saying Muto's is
that what it was in the first one yeah
so weird is like the movies that they
you know that they're basing them on
we're made for like [ __ ] two bucks
and now so this movie is so [ __ ]
expensive every time they show one of
them it's like oh that's not a puppet
like that's not a guy in a suit like
it's just been a serious [ __ ] money
on it but oh my god once they showed the
set of the shadow of monster zero King
Ghidorah
that was [ __ ] nuts oh this is the
world we live in we're getting them back
the king is back and then [ __ ]
Tywin Lannister says long live the king
so I guess that's it wins the game of
Thrones oh my god Godzilla and they got
Mothra Rodan Godzilla and King Ghidorah
that's it four of them yeah the trailer
looks [ __ ] bleak like it looks like
like and I'm not spoiling anything it's
in the [ __ ] trailer it looks like the
earth gets wrecked and then the [ __ ]
monsters come back oh yeah
which which I guess makes the whole like
plot of the we need them because you're
like who [ __ ] needs that but
apparently they're gonna stop whatever
that well it seems like they keep saying
in the trailer I don't know exactly how
but like that humans did this and humans
ended the world and how the Titans got
to save us so it seems like maybe kind
of a return to the Godzilla that is a
nuclear parable that is save us from
ourselves sort of parable or what have
we wrought sort of story so going back
there I'm in so it's but it basically
they're all gonna fight right yeah I
just hope so I don't want to go and they
hug it out I certainly don't want them
to be friends I don't know it's like I
kind of want to know if like Mothra and
Godzilla fight cuz like they've fought
before but also like they're kind of
friends in some of them I also think
like Mothra is the first one down be
like with those wings it's just you're
too [ __ ] delicate ready for this too
pretty for this world just pry the wings
off and then it's just a worm on the
ground [ __ ] away yeah man and then
Rodan's a girl needs an O there I
[ __ ] written it godzilla does the
weird dance jump from that one where he
goes up in the air will do that way and
then he's over again God Sookie it's all
good yeah
yeah I can't wait to see that flick the
first one was a little you know hey
there's gods oh oh and he's gone
there's gods oh oh and he's good like
they just did a fuchsia like way too
much human story in that I don't give a
[ __ ] about a human just show me a giant
monster stepping on [ __ ] over and over
you can make the movie ten minutes long
as long as it's just that [ __ ] like just
destruction fighting credit
done like I got a lot of [ __ ] to do I'd
be happy if it was shorter man
all right so ami I still got a trailer
for crimes of Grindelwald the new Harry
Potter movie I didn't know that action I
still haven't watched the first what was
it called fantastic beasts I've watched
all the Potter movies but I didn't watch
fantastic beasts did you know do you
know it look it's uh I love Harry Potter
books midnight releases watched all the
movies just fantastic beasts never got
around to it I missed it four other
completely nah it wasn't boycotting it
or anything I missed it for legit
reasons and then it never kind of came
around for me again I wasn't like dying
to go watch it and I don't know why that
is should I watch it is this a thing
that we like
I heard kind of bad things and I are
kind of good things I mean and I don't
think I've heard anything whatsoever
like and that neither batter and
different nobody's ever said like oh you
gotta watch this I love the world I will
I can skip this [ __ ] where all this [ __ ]
is mediocre like nobody's ever come and
I don't think I know anybody that's ever
seen it but it made enough money for
them to do it again I get a certain
point I just kind of forgot like and it
wasn't like on purpose sort of thing but
for me it was more like hey man do you
love Harry Potter well this ain't that
Oh know who this [ __ ] guy is you know
but he's going to America I'm like ah
[ __ ] I live there
those other movies were quite handsome
like I don't live over there this one
looks pretty cool though this one goes
back to Hogwarts a little bit this is
Jude Law's Dumbledore has a kid is the
one where Jude Law comes in yes and we
got a little bit of Nicolas Flamel cameo
at the end so there's a little bit of
Sorcerer's Stone connection to it so it
looks like they're gonna blame that what
do you mean source Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone
Nicholas Flamel real-life Alchemist guy
is kind of a minor character and it hits
his stone of immortality his a reference
to the Moors other movies they've like
referenced him and stuff and referenced
him in the movies and he's looks he has
a whole scene in the trailer where he
comes down he's like I'm Nicola Matlin
so they do know that world that's it you
know real well it's like a big deal but
they're clearly trying to dig real hard
into the Harry Potter stuff and like
actually get it into the world of stuff
people are I think they should because I
like that's part of the reason I didn't
watch the fantastic piece I'm like well
it's it's Potter adjacent but it's not
pot or burst but if you put in [ __ ]
Dumble dick I'm totally [ __ ] there
and you're seeing like sexy Dumbledore
like teaching at a school so he's like
you actually Ixia min a class with
students just lecturing Harry all the
time and well Harry I'm gonna try to
forget this [ __ ] and then puts it in his
pensive and women and then there was
glass also a superhero movie glass yeah
good trailer M night Shyamalan years ago
made a movie with Bruce Willis called
him breakable back at a time where
nobody who was really making comic-book
movies anymore and it's a wonderful
flick and then he wasn't made years
later split and in the tail end of split
spoilers one two three Bruce Willis is
sitting at the [ __ ] counter of this
joint and he is his character David Dunn
from unbreakable so the whole world was
like ah yet there's a backdoor
unbreakable sequel it sounds dirtier
than I meant it
so everyone got happy and then M night
was like yeah my making another one
called glass and you know if you know
unbreakable Sam Jackson's characters mr.
glass so think about it that movie age
is incredibly well the comic book movies
[ __ ] huge now everyone beat up on M
night a few years ago so he's gone
through his [ __ ] like we love him
[ __ ] him and now he's back I know you
know you do this so we're in the middle
of a Shyamalan Ahsan some sorts and
whatnot and like this movie looks legit
[ __ ] good and he laid the track in the
day and worked with Sam Jackson before
Sam Jackson was the Marvel guy so now
it's like all the ingredients are [ __ ]
there man it made sense for him do the
movie and the [ __ ] trailer looks
phenomenal it's great that one shot of
the [ __ ] guy from split just running
like a [ __ ] animal across it's great
yeah it's really good all of it [ __ ]
fantastic so yeah when does that come
out anybody know
January 18 2019 oh we gotta wait till no
we had a ways to go on that one [ __ ]
yeah
all right a reason to stay alive yeah a
lot what's your newest Harry Potter's
this year everything else I just said
was in 2019 so stay alive for a while
yeah man the Harry Potter thing I just
got to keep throwing in some characters
and [ __ ] from the other world that'll
get me interested yeah although I'm sure
they're like we're doing fine without
your [ __ ] 10 bucks go [ __ ] yourself
[ __ ] muggle what else we've got sit
for the big movie trailers I got comic
book news since it is a Comic Con flyer
because I always feel bad when the
movies take over and all these comic
books are coming out there is source
material where they get all those funny
and fun and expensive movies from man
the source material is still good they
tell me I'll be honest with you though I
don't read a [ __ ] ton of comics like I
used to and not because of my comics
suck you know I had my era and then both
the big two flipped continuities many
[ __ ] times and you know I don't blame
them that's how you get new people to
come in or keep old people may be
interested but you know the world I was
interested in the continuity I came in
with
post-crisis world like once dc1 new 52 I
was like oh all right well this these
are for someone else not for me and I
get it I get that they have to do this
but there was a certain freedom and like
oh [ __ ] I don't have to read everything
anymore because this is not my universe
and I think there was a lot of people
that did the same thing same thing
happens Marvel Marvel also rebooted a
number of times even before DC you know
they were the ones of heroes reborn back
in the day so you know at once you
realize oh [ __ ] like this it's a medium
that's always gonna regenerate itself
with fresh blood fresh storylines fresh
writers fresh artists to appeal to a
younger generation suddenly I was like
oh I don't have to read everything and
so now I'm Way more [ __ ] selective
about what I read what I've been getting
hit with a lot on Twitter this week to
the point where they pushed me over the
edge is we were talking a few episodes
back about Star Wars movies instead of
solo - a Darth Vader movie can't you do
the Jesus years you know between [ __ ]
the prevent you know avenge of the Sith
and [ __ ] Star Wars and [ __ ] like the
rogue one era how do you get to rogue
one where he's a [ __ ] badass and [ __ ]
and so people were like well why don't
you just read the current comics that
and I forget the name of the writer
anybody Karen Gillan is that his name
it's a guy yeah
and he's writing about Dora the Darth
Vader series yeah yeah yeah it's really
good is that so everyone's saying they
likes [ __ ] dope so I'm actually dive
into that and read that who publishes
dark know Marvel has Marvel it switched
over yeah yeah and they got new comics
coming out they got my friend actually
Jodie Hauser is a great comic book
writer is putting out the first kind of
arc age of Republic so going back to
kind of the Clone Wars prequel era and
doing like the first issues like a Darth
Maul thing and it's all gonna build
through the rebellion era and then the
resistance era and they're doing like a
twenty four thirty issue like a maxi
series that takes you across the whole
span of the saga with different writers
and artists and stuff so that's
happening that's kind of a big deal yeah
the numbers are like all those Star Wars
books are selling for them right they
must be gonna keep making new ones so
they must be you also got Grant Morrison
and Liam
sharp getting on Green Lantern which if
anybody should be writing Green Lantern
it's grant [ __ ] is such a good idea
man I get into the weird [ __ ] I know
Jeff is a big fan of the character and
he did some wonderful work with it but
that would make me pick up a green
lantern I love when Grant Morrison does
mainstream because he takes the toys
that you think you know how to play with
and shows you how to play with them in a
very different way sometimes he's like
stick this one up your arse but still
it's always very [ __ ] interesting and
you're right he's an imaginative [ __ ]
guy give him the character who's
supposed to be the most imaginative
[ __ ] person in the DC Universe the
ring you know goes to the [ __ ] person
that it needs to and so one would assume
if it went to Hal Jordan since the ring
is powered by imagination that he must
be the most imaginative program in the
DC universe and stuff and still every
time he's like a giant baseball glove
man oh yeah
so I would like to see what Grant
Morrison does the character he will
build some [ __ ] up constructs what's
so weird about it is that like I
expected them to announce it and him to
be like it's gonna be the craziest acid
trip you've ever been on
he said no Hal Jordans a space cop we're
gonna do it like a cop procedural in the
Green Lantern universe but we're gonna
make it weird
in the cop procedural world I was like
that is not what I expected
that's not that's I think I like mine
better I think he's gonna do it
but Alan Moore did space cop too but
then there were like leather Green
Lantern's that were like I'm a song I'm
a song given life I'm a math equation
and I'm a Green Lantern from the Swamp
Thing yeah remember the issue of The
Swamp Thing run where it was a planet of
vegetation Swamp Thing was like jumping
around the galaxy as consciousness was
like out in space so he's going
throughout the galaxy trying to get back
to Abby on earth and stuff and wherever
he goes he builds like a body a husk out
of the plant life so he goes this one
planet
and builds a body and there's like
millions of screaming voices because all
the vegetation is sentient so for him to
build the body means to kill all these
[ __ ] people yeah such a good [ __ ]
story so good
alright so that's cool so we got that we
got a Kelly sue Taconic one of my
favorite comics writers working with
Robson Roca and doing speaking of
Aquaman Aquaman doing a big reboot of
Aquaman and making him cool again so
they're going all in on the Aquaman
thing look they're gonna be launched in
all that movie that's probably a smart
move they're gonna I guess make them
look a little more like Momoa I don't
know they have it oh no they've released
any art from it but I bet they do
something like that I would imagine
that'd be the smart play right now if
he's what the kid sees Aquaman go in
that direction and whatnot the days of
the orange shoot are certain blonde hair
long behind us yeah and then there was
uh the Eisner Awards comics big award
night the Oscars of the comic book
community yeah big winner was monstrous
Marjorie Liu wrote it yeah there's the
monsters fan she did it she did with a
sonnet Takata and it won [ __ ]
everything including winning Marjorie
Liu the best writer award shared with
Tom King Wow but the first woman to win
best writer at the eisenerz which is
crazy to me oh you [ __ ] suck increase
oh my god give it up for history
Marjorie Liu she was she was cool about
it she couldn't believe it either she
went on Twitter and she was like I'm
first that's not when you say she shared
with Tom King they didn't write together
but no they so they tied for best writer
which is pretty so I guess there's an
even number of voters for the eisenerz
his was for Batman his was for it's for
your body of work for the year and I
wasn't there but apparently so Nichelle
Nichols from Star Trek or was was kind
of announcing it and was she kept having
to say because Tom King did a Batman
Elmer Fudd crossover this year so every
award Tom came one somebody up on stage
had to be like and Tom King for Batman
Batman Elmer Fudd and
yeah so they were bit befuddled by this
I have you read the Batman Elmer Fudd
it's it's it's super cool it's like so
much cooler than you'd think it all the
crossovers they did with hanna-barbera
are really really great the Elmer Fudd
one's the best one it's one issue so you
could just like what was it they're like
dead serious takes on the hanna-barbera
character so it's a gritty noir hunter
version of over Fudd and Elmer Fudd
looking for a rabbit the whole time or
no no each shows up in a bar in Gotham
City and goes on from there but whatever
what's what does he want
it's uh-oh who's hunting wabbits wabbits
you guys should read it it's great I
mean there's a lot of there's a lot of
Eisner you've gone but the big ones are
big ones they're Marjorie Liu and you
got Mitch Jarrod's one best penciler for
mr. miracle she's also fantastic right
on
and then Santa Kato won a bunch for
monstrous best cover artist best painter
for monstrous monstrous yeah it's a
continuing image series it's been around
since like 2015 I read like yeah the
first arc it's a girl with kind of
tentacles come out of her arm and she's
like a monster figure and she's learning
to control her power and [ __ ] so check
it out man yeah and then Batman the
Animated Series coming out on blu-ray
that was the last piece I wrote that at
the end finally every whole thing comes
with mask of the phantasm and Batman
sub-zero surprisingly cheap it comes the
phantasm as well yeah it comes with the
two movies that came out and I know I'm
like I shouldn't give a [ __ ] cuz I'm
like I can watch him on [ __ ] iTunes
and stuff like that but that is sweet
man having that box set and I saw the
box they did a restoration for it too so
it looks unreal good what do you mean
like they showed a split screen I was at
this panel and they showed a split
screen of what it looked like before and
then what the blu-ray looks like and
everything is smooth so when like the
cameras panning or tilting or whatever
instead of being kind of like jittery
down like a smooth [ __ ] tilting pan
now all the colors are cleaned up they
fully remastered I kind of couldn't
believe how good it looked good I am
alright then I'm definitely there's that
but you can pre-order it hopefully
they'll send me a free copy but I'll buy
one as well
you could buy is that all the news
that's all the news face all the news
give it up for Eric Ebron geo news all
right we got a guest that we get to talk
to tonight ladies and gentlemen and it's
for us a friend of ours somebody that we
kind of dig and we're gonna work with
and stuff but she's worked in the field
she's responsible for crime number one
she's an artist whose work I love number
two in this world particularly did you
ever see the DC superhero girls anybody
watch that it starts with an amazing
little theme song get your cape on and
let's take flight we can be who we like
get your cape it's definitely for little
girls but this 47 year old man loves it
as well it's a great take on the DC
Universe like with kids
essentially that all as all the
characters as kids who went to school
together
yeah heroes and villains a middle
schooler hey I mean it looks like high
school to me I think but we'll be able
to talk to her pernil designed all the
characters man and these characters I
see all the time because I love the
cartoons but Jason muses kid Logan
that's all she plays with Minnie Mouse
and the DC superhero girls if you've
been near a toy store or an airport in
the last year man they sell them all
over the [ __ ] place but we're going
to talk to her about drawing and design
man she's from Denmark so I have a hard
time with the last name so I'm just
gonna say her Neil come on up man
philony a name do the last name boom oh
[ __ ] oh we were never gonna get that
totally you asked me and I was like oh
yeah it's close enough it's good yeah
for Niels out here because she just went
to comic-con for the first time is that
it yes how long you been drawn I've
always always thrown but I've been a
freelancer for the last four years
when did you start drawing when did you
know you could draw I was liked drawing
but I I also knew at an early age oh I
can't draw and I wish I could cuz if I
did I wouldn't [ __ ] subject people
those terrible movies I make but that
that was nothing I had no drawing talent
whatsoever when did you realize like oh
my horse looks like a horse I don't
really know it's just always been the
thing that I did I was always the one in
the kindergarden who drew and stuff when
I was I think four years old I went to
see The Little Mermaid and I just knew
that that's what I wanted to do so I was
just I didn't have a back-up plan at all
so I'm really really happy that it
panned out yeah it certainly the alright
so word Tom where you come from Denmark
was it like over there compared to here
growing up fewer people yeah it's really
small country there's six million people
in total and what is that what was your
like pop culture background growing up
do they get the same [ __ ] we get here
yeah but like in a smaller run we had a
really cool guy who went through all the
comics that came out here and then he
published some of the stories into like
what he thought would make a cohesive
story without publishing everything so
but there wasn't a lot of it but I used
to go to all these they had these weird
shops imagine 12 year old me and half
the Shelf was comic books and the other
half was porn
so that's how it is so I always went in
and I went to the left and I went
through all the the magazines and stuff
and I always like I was collecting
spider-man a lot and oh there's some web
shooting going on there I'm sure was
there until you walked in then there
like everybody quiet down little girls
here alright she's [ __ ] gone back to
it was there a curtain there was a guy
going left left right right well then
what was the first people to have free
porn so what do you mean free porn or
porn that was that it was legal that
happened in the city you still had to
buy it yeah I was like free porn
okay so at a young age you you're into
as many comics as you get your hands on
stuff when did you I guess with a little
mermaid is when you realize you were
Disney kid yeah I always wanted to do
animation my plan was to go into 2d
animation and I went to school to become
an animator but as soon as it got out of
school it turned out I had to work with
3d and visual effects and I never got to
draw so I ended up you know I actually
worked in London and the John Carter
movie you worked on there yeah I did the
some of the aliens in the background and
that's when I realized that I didn't
want to do that so I quit why how did
you come to that conclusion was it long
or was it just like this is not what I
was what and what do you do what did you
do exactly on a character draw character
no no not at all I had nothing to do
with drawing I was just animating so it
was when I was oh oh [ __ ] look who's
back ladies gentlemen smart bernard i'm
saved i'm saved we were just in the
middle of speaking to pernil here man
tell us so wait a second so was I just
talking about before I got [ __ ]
hugged Jung Carter John Carter so what
is the difference are you woody what do
you mean when you say animating what do
you it's because when you work in 3d
animation you don't draw but you more
you more move around the characters so
all the principles that I learned from
doing animation I could apply those to a
3d character in the computer but it I
didn't need my my drawing skills so I
ended up sitting there drawing while you
do something that's called rendering
where you you move the character around
and then you make a computer play it out
for you and it takes like half an hour
sometimes so is sit there and doodle and
people around me were very surprised
that I could draw and that's kind of
like when I started realizing okay I
don't this is not where I want to be I
want to be with other people who can
draw I don't want to pursue that dream
so I quit and moved back to Denmark and
started figuring out to become a
character designer instead so what is so
in that in that instance are you scared
because you're like oh [ __ ] like I had a
legit job in animation but it wasn't
we've got your dream but you hit the
target but missed the tree yeah it was
kind it was really hard I realized
really quickly that I didn't want to be
there but it took a long time for me to
or seven or eight months for me to
realize that that was like I needed to
do something about it I moved back so
how did you make a living afterwards
well really quickly I have know a lot of
people in the animation business in
Denmark I started doing background and a
bit of animation as well just you know
keep afloat and then I got hired by a
gaming company and while I was there I
got contacted from Warner Brothers and
that's when I went freelance
so what Warner Brothers just contacts
you out of the blue house that happened
have they seen your stuff yeah they saw
my stuff online I had I have an
Instagram where I post my work so
basically first of all like I contacted
my Mattel and it it's a few takes on
what I thought that the DC superhero
girls would be but we couldn't agree on
how the show was gonna look right so we
split ways which happens all the time
but then more or one of others came in
and took over the TV show and
they ended up liking the designs that I
had done for Mattel and they called me
back in and I ended up designing the
whole thing so what does that entail
that means like somebody says this is
what here are the characters names these
are the concepts bring it to life like
you don't start with any imagery
whatsoever no they sent me because a lot
of artists have done different versions
of different heroes so they go in and
like we like this look and we like this
part of it the main characters took a
long time to design like we went a lot
through a lot with for instance Wonder
Woman and how the whole look of the show
was gonna be it was gonna be based on my
art style but later on like when it was
like the like the like granny goodness
you're not gonna spend months working on
her it's it was one of the quicker ones
so we just look at imagery and it bit
back and forth and you create them more
quickly Barbara Gordon's character her
Batgirl has a her it's a hoodie yeah it
makes her Batgirl was that you yeah
that's so [ __ ] up cause like that's
it's beautiful number one applause for
that thank you but it's on all the toys
and dolls man yeah I'm really proud of
that there was one of my favorite things
because it's it seems like why not white
so it's right there yeah yeah incredible
and when I looked at it I was like oh
[ __ ] no but he's done this before what
else did you get to bring to it where
you're like oh nobody's done like when
you walk away from the job what do you
go like these are the three things that
I love about everything I do well the
main thing that I really love is the
shoes like it's the fact that I I was
the one whose persistence that they were
flat shoes because I've always been
annoyed when you see superheroes running
around in high heels like I can't walk
down the street hi you didn't make some
women can run from a dinosaur in high
heels
to a scene in the movie once away a
second one that's true so wait they the
characters originally they were like put
him in heels and you're like hey man can
we put him in fly it was very monster
high in the very early stage of it
yeah then we pulled it and that's also
when Warner Brothers came in some the
thing I'm most proud about is the fact
that kids could wear the outfits that I
put them in like all of them like it's
always like covered nicely and it's very
wearable and stuff like that and that's
something I always missed when I was a
kid because I love superheroes as well
so the fact that it's it's wearable it's
also that's something I'm very wearable
as opposed to like [ __ ] here's a
piece of pasties that go across here
yeah the outfits weren't like they
really nobody showed off skin but you
got the definite impression of costume
yeah not [ __ ] sure so that was you as
well yeah yeah that was me and it
Jennifer Corley the director and her and
I were the ones who got the thing back
on because DC were actually gonna pull
out from the project they didn't they
weren't sure that they liked what they
saw
and that's when Jennifer saw the artwork
I did for Mattel so she she just took
the artwork without like it's because it
had to be fast you just took my artwork
drew on it a little bit and just send it
to DC who were like okay if you're gonna
do that we can do work with you and then
she called me and I was like so
I kind of used your artwork to get this
job to work with me so it was like a
backwards way of doing it but it was
great so yeah so we worked really close
even though I worked from Denmark while
I was doing it so she was here and you
were all the way over there but I guess
it don't matter if I online no it was
actually perfect time wise because I had
the whole day but due to the time
difference and then I could turn
something in at the end of the day and
the next day I would have feedback and
stuff this is just what I want to take a
moment to shout out like there's an
entire generation of kids and more
importantly an entire generation of
girls who are being presented with a
version of the characters that you put
together that are body-positive you know
Sam like without the mandatory like look
at this [ __ ] shows off the curbs and
[ __ ] like that that's that's I mean who
knows what happens to that generation
you know what I'm saying like somebody's
shown something different maybe they
kind of take it in a different direction
you might have just changed comics
history a little bit
I hope so like I definitely tried to
contribute I saw a lot of amazing kids
at the comic-con wearing outfits that
were based on the stuff that I did like
I just wanted to run over to them and
like I did this but I thought the Danish
woman's all over me yeah I think it
wouldn't have gone on to all so that is
[ __ ] phenomenal so what does we're
number one where where can they find
your work online what's the Instagram
its pranaya Lauren good luck yeah and
what is the website also
Peniel it's Pony pernil Oh a dot-com all
right you better spell it for everybody
those listening go ahead yeah it's P er
and il le right what do you do what do
you what were you doing in San Diego do
you have a table yes I was lucky enough
to be invited by the gallery nucleus
from LA they have a few amazing artists
that that are showing from their booth
so they asked me to come over which was
pretty big because it's my first con
ever I had no idea what I was stepping
into it's what do you think what do you
make of it it was insane I think I still
need to digest because so many things
happen and you had no idea like didn't
see any of the stuff you guys were
talking about but I saw some yeah bunch
of other stuff we saw completely
different comic-con
yes
were you in our is that are they an
artist alley I know there were some are
well it was pretty good
next to Marvel that was yeah I was
looking at the new Marvel video game the
whole like the trailer I'm definitely
buying it marketing works yes it does
September 7 when and you know the date
as well what what does one do there do
you bring prints to sell and stuff like
that yes I have a new book out that just
came out Thursday that I brought and I
have two older books where one of them
you helped me out with the forward and
then a bunch of prints and I did an eye
mask as well which so really well which
was kind of cool heywhat and I'm asked
for sleeping like for the plane yeah you
you made what I mean I got some mate I
have produced some like a design some I
got my masks yes where's that have to do
with anything man I can wait you
designed it so lost I know it's so wait
is that a side business you're like you
know I'm awesome
I also believe in good I care they've
got dirt on their homes by the way I
thought it was weird too but I almost
bought one what is a [ __ ] cool well
there's one that's like looks like a
face in the drawing style of mines
there's like eyes and the other one is
just a part of the cover from my new
book and they they sold pieces like come
out of this not like this is creepy no
no a lot of people is for sleeping like
I said yeah airplane stuff do you get a
beautiful cartoon eyes does Denmark have
too much Sun or something like that's
awesome or GM made over there yeah and
then I had to ship him out yeah I had
everything with me in back since you
brought it with you on the plane I only
lost one so lost what one mass went one
bag a whole [ __ ] bag and I got it
back just what do you mean I only lost
one as if like that's acceptable well
I lost 500 books the last time I came
over here what shipping is not I don't
think that's losing I think people are
stealing your [ __ ] yeah I can see why
this time around you're like just one
bag yeah that's good right on man so
what are you gonna work on next like
what are you working on now and what are
you hoping to do well I'm doing a few
and you working with a new license where
we're going to do some books and I've
did the character designs for that and I
am also working on a feature where I'm
doing a bit of character design
fuckin'-a now is that gratifying I think
so it's one of those where they have
everything kind of sorted out but they
needed me to take a take on the female
lead so I'm really excited to try that
out and didn't you do one of the book or
something like that for the DC super
yeah I did two story books for DC so
which ones were that they were shut down
in space and I should remember the other
one it's the one with I actually forgot
I loved it
no worries but was it weird to get that
gig and they're like can you draw like
this yeah the first one they asked me
like I think there's stuff so it's
really well with this it's like I didn't
know no like a lot of people don't know
that I worked in this show so it's like
wow your Styles gonna be great just like
this you like it sure [ __ ] is makes
this [ __ ] Dane very melancholy when
you don't [ __ ] knowledge that well
that happened at Comic Con actually
somebody came over and they were looking
at my prints looking at my booth and
they're like hmm I think you're just
stealing your style from DC superhero
girl
well I [ __ ] love you work III was the
first exposed to it when you did a piece
that Ralph put up on the screen on
Hollywood babble-on
ano goes then he also did me in Ralph as
well it's beautiful beautiful stuff and
I loved the character design of the DC
superhero girls Ben I love the ethos of
the whole thing but [ __ ] they were just
insanely well design adorable to look at
hopefully keep [ __ ] going man and
hopefully check back in next year we'll
hear about the feature me pernil and
eric are working on a comic book
together that which I'm kind of happy
about isn't set in America that was our
big yeah breakthrough like we were
sitting there gone like wow we could set
it here set it here but we were like why
don't we set it in a place we it wasn't
originally Denmark it was like where it
was Switzerland Switzerland I was like
it's you know in Switzerland the
government funds all the cows like it
was one of those dopey pieces of trivia
I brought back from Switzerland I was
like let's set the [ __ ] story in
Switzerland man I'd be nuts and as we
were sitting there developing it Pernell
was just like can we if we're gonna set
it in arbitrarily in Switzerland can we
do it in Denmark because I know what
Denmark [ __ ] looks like yeah like oh
yeah that makes sense was so polite she
was like is there a specific reason that
it they must be like are you Swiss know
somebody in Switzerland cuz we're like
know it Kevin had a yeah was stoned and
I remembered something but but as soon
as we can tell you more about it we will
but until that man continued [ __ ]
success show him that show him the piece
of artwork hold it up before we let you
go so they could see the steez here's
one
that's this time I go to look at her
Instagram you can see a bunch of stuff
glad you got to come and join us man I
will always want to shout you out for
the DC superhero girls and glad we got
to do it give it up for Peniel everybody
thank you so so so what'd I miss what
did you miss
we went through [ __ ] two hours of
comic-con news is it so much we covered
everything but we've been waiting for
you to come back I say Castle Rock we've
said we didn't even touch Castle Rock
and stuff but this is not hardly a bar
for two people let alone three so while
he has [ __ ] held down the fort man
Eric is ready to surrender his position
to mark him out yeah way to kick him out
give it up for the amazing
Eric Carrasco an excellent job man
excellent job all right captain tell us
about the party you just said you were
about how was it uh it was pretty
awesome was pretty awesome I got that
beautiful screening room in there so we
watched the first two episodes and there
was baby cheeseburgers and sushi and
beer so and and the entire writing staff
was there which is cool I hadn't seen
those guys in like a year so it was a
lovely sort of celebration for the thing
we did way back when how many episodes
just one episode you guys well yeah we
watched it we watched at the two-part
pilot any of the cast or no just you
guys just us the cast was most of them
were in San Diego I got to roll with
Bill skarsgård who is like a Beatle he
is particularly in that world yeah yeah
well it's man he's like the tallest
Beatle really he's like [ __ ] if Ringo
stood on George's [ __ ] shoulders he's
so [ __ ] like rob a bank yeah he's
like his brother is the one you know
he's Eric the vampire from true
Alexander Skarsgard his father is
stellan skarsgård for all three things
[ __ ] tall man just [ __ ] Giants
[ __ ] where they come
Denmark do they really are they are they
Sweden
sorry different it's the same oh it's
not I'm so glad she said it because I
was just about to alright so he was a
nice guy I met him at Sundance nice guy
he seems very like oh my god like
embarrassed by all the Pennywise
attention yeah a little bit yeah a
little bit but he's also a little bit
like a like a like a tennis pro like
he's tall and thin and a little bit
gaunt and kind of loose like he's okay
listen I'll totally teach your girl how
to play tennis but I gotta smoke this
bowl first oh it's my kind of tennis
[ __ ] pro I think so yeah so how was
you did the panel when you were in I did
the panel which was it was it was
awesome and wonderful but totally
surreal because I know everything there
is to know about the show right so
moderating a panel you have to pretend
like you don't like I'm ask you some
questions and give some answers that I
know what the answers are but I got to
set you up an underhand softball you
some [ __ ] that you're gonna hammer out
of the room alright so let's talk about
I told them the story about how I was
sitting there and all of a sudden I won
an inkpot but I understand you have a
very similar story I do have a very
similar story I had a spotlight panel
which I imagine is like what your Hall H
panel is like with five thousand nine
hundred less people oh yeah I've not in
Hall H I wasn't like 29a be heard you're
a room at the hotel totally a couple
people came in you'd left the door open
you guys want a beer come on in let's
talk about comic books that's what I
said to myself going to spend I said
listen I got twenty dollars in my pocket
if when I get to this panel there are
enough people there that with that
twenty dollars I could buy each of them
a drink let's go do that yeah but but I
got there and I was like you know
hundred people who had showed up which
was super lovely and then Gary sassman
who is the VP of like print promotions
and publicity and all of that [ __ ] for
the convention gets up he's like well
those would be arrow for spotlight
panelists we want to you know we always
like to come and give them a lunch
reduction and so we gets up there and
his [ __ ] speech and it's like hey so
mark first contribution of years of
service to the comic-book arts as a
journalist as a podcast or as a comic
book writer we would like to present him
with a 20-18 inkpot award Wow she told
me this I don't want something better
and then I had a buddy of mine
Evan Narcisse who was part of the Black
Panther roundtable we did well I've
known for 15 years right he's a
journalist Friday 9:00 he worked for
time 14 people like he wrote these
rights
rise of the Black Panther for Marvel I
asked him okay could you moderate this
panel I'm just gonna have somebody to
talk to for an hour look sure and then
he gives this [ __ ] speech and the
speech is like do I have a terminal
disease nobody like is this the last is
this my wake you know and like I start
crying and he's crying he can't get to
the speech and I'm crying even worse and
if people in the crowd a cry and we're
all [ __ ] crying I got this award
that's not getting wet with tears and it
was the most beautiful unsurprised like
unexpected thing to happen my entire
convention and there was a haunted house
based on the show that I wrote on yeah
like this was this was a parade of
Surrey ality for you as a weird
wonderful con it really was and and
we'll never get another one like it I
don't think you know cuz again your
first count as your first count your
first con was something amazing happens
it's yeah I just I I didn't have words
for it and I still don't really it's so
like [ __ ] wonderful that we both won
inkpots I know but not for this show
we're all we do is talk about that [ __ ]
still man it was [ __ ] lovely really
did you know you were getting no [ __ ]
clue
none honestly none whatsoever I was
telling them earlier like I hope to win
one before I died I was like well maybe
if I'm still alive Stan's age and I'm
still kicking around comic-con the be
like here's your award [ __ ] off but they
they hit me early man because the
because the heart attack but whatever
I'll take it Hey it was [ __ ] nice I
instantly took it home and put it like
on a shelf and just [ __ ] stare at it
like it means the absolute [ __ ] world
to me Comic Con was a place I always
wanted to go up until the moment I got
to go in 1995 always dreamed of going
there or
read about it and stuff and ever since
1995 I've been going back so to have
them be like one of us one of us and I
don't know if you did what I did but I
instantly went and looked at the list of
winners it's nuts it's like your
shoulder to shoulder with the people who
created your childhood the people whose
work you've long adored Steven
Spielberg's got one [ __ ] they gave
one to Kevin Feige last year Grant
Morrison's got one Hill Adams got one is
like it's [ __ ] crazy so it was a
wonderful comic-con for that alone man
but yeah they kept it quiet I had no
[ __ ] clue like eyes if they told me
I'd have come and given you yours yeah
I'll give it a big speech make you cry
like a [ __ ] I mean not that is that
hard but it's true man you can just be
like hey keV did you see that
Christopher Robin trailer my god Ron
Kevin run
did you see ad you get interfered with
the traffic Hollywood Boulevard traffic
are they doing a thing down there today
Quentin Tarantino thing oh [ __ ] we
shooting this movie apparently they
turned it into the 60s a few blocks away
wow what the [ __ ] are we doing here
that's what I said [ __ ] this let's go
look at it let's go stare and [ __ ] like
that
if you come with me there's a good
chance I can get us on set man he might
be like is that Kevin the shoulders have
like a dozen children I I don't like
going to the sets of my own movies let
alone other people's movies but yeah
he's shooting right down the [ __ ]
that's awesome I know pretty well
alright man that somebody said that Brad
Pitt was walking up and down the street
right next year would of what what is it
the one where Sharky's is cuenca he was
like you know I guess they were shooting
up there so he's just chilling walking
up and down laughing brought him in to
talk about some stuff
I know really a man [ __ ] number cool
world
oh you reached way back he's like you
know man this is why I stopped coming
into bars cuz whenever I do people like
hey cool world
[ __ ] this quit man
alright man so it sounds like you had a
great con a grand a great con I had a
good night I am but I could not stay
away I know I'm so delighted you arrived
here just in time to get to everyone's
favorite part of fat man on Batman Q&A
ladies and gentlemen as per usual our
good friend deacon who works over at 4dx
has given us some contraband man 10
tickets to 40x
theater they got it down in LA alive 2
tickets a pop so you don't go alone and
stuff like that if you've never been to
a 40x movie my god what are you waiting
for it makes whatever is happening on
the screen happen in real life so if
it's snowing on the screen it snows in
the theater if somebody's getting blown
on screen you're getting blown in the
thing you are not know you won't but
it's almost as good it's pretty [ __ ]
astounding if you're if you're gonna see
a big-budget movie and stuff see it in
40 X we got five sets of tickets two
tickets apiece but we also have and we
thank Deacon for getting those tickets
for us put it together for 40 X and
Deacon ladies and gentlemen
no wait there's a special right but we
also have a sixth a little prize to give
away tonight so that means we'll have
six questions the sixth and final
question the evening ladies and
gentlemen will be for a giveaway for one
pair of tickets to go see the Empire
Strikes Back at the Hollywood Bowl with
a huge [ __ ] Orchestra the a Los
Angeles Philharmonic conducted by David
Newman doing John Williams iconic score
live feel the force on August 9th 2018
with special screening of Star Wars new
hope August 7th and 10th and the Empire
Strikes Back August 9th and 11th watch
the movie and the Bulls spectacular HD
screen it's [ __ ] amazing that screen
I've never been this would be even you
want to win these yeah can I ask a
question they will I believe JC said
they were gonna hook us up with a
[ __ ] booth if you wanted to go watch
the movie yeah this is your year mark
I'm just coming up millhouse it really
is yeah man is if you've never been to
the bowl this would be the way to go see
it Empire Strikes Back with a huge
[ __ ] score if you can't win these
tickets you can go get tickets right now
at the Hollywood Bowl dot-com Hollywood
Bowl where summer plays so our sixth
question we'll get somebody to tickets
go see Empire Strikes Back at the
Hollywood Bowl JC the prior this year
fine establishment where we do the show
every week here at the scum and villainy
Cantina on Hollywood Boulevard here in
the heart of Hollywood put your hands
together to the folks at home
JC has gone out and picked a person for
us to start the Q&A with what's your
name kind sir my name is David give it
up for David everybody congratulations
on the inkpots as well they both so well
dad thank you what can we do you for sir
do you want these all we ask is that you
ask me and Mark a question that both of
us can answer something that's not so
I've been working in the animation
industry for two years and this is my
first year in which I've been lucky
enough to get into the story room to
actually be close to the action and I
know that you know what that feels like
but I'm sure you also know what it feels
like to be loving what you're doing but
struggling to find a work-life balance
and there's so much white noise and
distraction especially in this town that
can take you away from your Center and
to me I believe you guys are both proof
positive that you can go through this
industry without that industry changing
you for the worse and so I would like to
ask you both what do you guys both do to
remain grounded focus on what really
matters in life and blot out all the
stuff that doesn't I smoke a lot of weed
and I'm not just saying that like in a
braggy I'm baked kind of way but
honestly it gives me perspective at all
[ __ ] times it helps me disconnect
from work as well sometimes just
important to get up in your head and
heart and not necessarily be working on
your career and stuff like that and of
course it's important to relate to
others but sometimes you just need to be
alone to kind of recalibrate reset and
go forward me time is very important I'm
not just talking about jerking off
although that is a part of it as well
but time to sit around and imagine
that's something that generally one does
by themselves once you start imagining
out loud with somebody well that's
planning that's a completely different
thing but we need to sit around and just
get up in our head and hearts man
because that's what shows you the future
that's what helps you pick a direct
so yeah it's important to work your ass
off in the moment you get your foot in
the door believe me I know from the
moment they picked up clerks
I've been going going nice stuff never
took time off or anything like that
always setting up the next thing or the
next three things while I'm working on
the present thing because I want to stay
where you know in the room where it
happens and stuff but it's still
important to maintain a sense of self
leave you time you know even if there
are distractions in this town and stuff
like that and work takes up so much of
what we are because it's not standard
work if it was like you know [ __ ] a
nine-to-five type job type job you have
no problem
[ __ ] balancing personal life and work
life the danger is when you're working
in something that you [ __ ] love you
can get lost that's why get ripped
that's yeah it's sacrifice just get in
the head man like just make sure you
leave yourself an hour every day some
people like to do like a writing thing
of like I try to write two pages every
day I always say leave yourself an hour
in a very busy schedule even if you have
to get up early to do it to just sit and
think because it's gives you a chance to
breathe so often we're doing sometimes
you got to stop and think you I I think
it's similar to the way you view it I
whenever I'm working on a project or on
a show or on whatever it is I like to
give myself a prize you know at the end
of it you know for a while it was
there's a video game I always wanted to
play I can't play it until I do this
draft and then when I've done with the
draft I can crack up and Skyrim and then
lose months like and it's and it's every
time you have some you got a job a
little accomplishment you finish the
draft like find a way to treat yourself
for it so that you're incentivizing
yourself as you go and also for me it's
it's remembering a bit where I came from
and how hard it was to get here you know
like the how lucky we are to be alive
right now
to do what we do and and never forget
that like there are people to reserve to
recounting on you you know like I've got
a family I've got friends I've got
parents I've got grandparents all of
which sacrificed something along the way
so that I could chase this [ __ ]
happy dream you know and to remember
that like for them like doing the work
is not only pleasing to me and I'm so
lucky that I get to do what I love to do
but it's remembering that that I'm
standing on the shoulders of giants all
of which you never got to see this far
and it helps me it helps me Center
myself and helps me remember why I do
the things that I do not just because it
makes me tickled to write he punches him
in the throat in this episode like a
hundred times because throat punches are
awesome and lasers are even better and
if you could have a car chase with a
laser and throat punching then I take my
money I just wrote a scene with a laser
in it today did you yeah I was soda
laughs never written the term laser
rifle oh it's so much fun it looked a
little goofy but I could work with it oh
what's new to the boots didn't look to
shake but yeah like so much of it is is
giving yourself time to be the kid you
used to be and also remember that your
adult who has to do a job but find a way
to make those things harmonize and and
you know kiss your kids when you can
thanks guys that is a great question so
great that I'm gonna give you the choice
between the four DX tickets or the
Hollywood Bowl tickets which one you
want absolute ikut see there are two
tickets to go to see a movie in 40 X or
two tickets to go see Empire Strikes
Back at the Hollywood ball on August 9th
and personal eggs back you deserve it
great question
pleasure man pleasure no no no stuff but
here don't leave me hanging don't leave
me hanging
oh [ __ ] he's leaving me hanging well so
Jake is in alright now we got five sets
of 40 eggs tickets to give out right now
mark mark you're standing next to me JC
who is our next question asker [ __ ]
person is you hi my name is Matt Matt I
will give it up for Matt ladies and
gentlemen do I bow an hour after ya take
your brows my friend I have to apologize
in advance this isn't actually a
question okay and it's more of a story
I've been waiting to tell Kevin for 18
years holy [ __ ] that's awesome you're
not going tickets booked and ready to
accept alright so the first time I saw
the trailer for clerks I was about eight
years old
Wayne's World was a family favorite
movie for me my brother and sister and
my parents and the trailer for clerks
was on it and I was like when I'm old
enough to rent raided our movies I gotta
see that movie so around 12 years old
you kind of got a gateway with the
occasional rated R movie well around 14
years old my brother committed suicide
[ __ ] I'm sorry I didn't see that going
so after about three or four days of not
really being able to sleep and you know
not going to school I was just like I
need to laugh so I went to the store and
I rented three movies one of them being
clerks and it took me out of that that
really terrible situation for an hour
and a half and I laughed my ass off and
I don't think I thought about it for at
least an hour and a half and I must have
watched that movie at least ten times I
always knew I was waiting to rent it at
a special time I just didn't know when
so I know the struggles and the
sacrifices you made to make that movie
so thank you very much oh my god
[Music]
thank you for the opportunity to tell
this story as well
I've been waiting 18 years for that
number one I'm sorry about your loss
number two that you you know we do this
[ __ ] goes as [ __ ] fun and you hope
you know it's useful to somebody
somewhere you're gonna make it useful
for yourself right build a career off it
but you always hope that people connect
with the material and stuff at least
they find it funny but when you meet
people who are like hey man that movie
was a life preserver at the right moment
in time I know what that [ __ ] means
I've had many songs movies TV shows that
made the difference between me being
here in and of not me being here me not
being here but me being here present and
me being full of hurt heartsick and [ __ ]
like that
so when somebody connects the material
at the right [ __ ] time it can be a
life raft it's happened to me I'm
honored to hear that it happened to you
with some goofy [ __ ] [ __ ] that I made
up man and it may not be a question but
[ __ ] that deserves tickets give it up
for my as a job man
[Applause]
alright [ __ ] that's moving boy good luck
following that [ __ ]
whatever you say they seem real [ __ ]
small where I can't fall wish you ain't
my friend Dan everyone give it up for
Dan thank you my wife and I are from
Oregon we watch your show like every
week we love it is one of the things
when I do when we came down here
anniversary this week so thank you so um
I will like theme parks I'm an ex Disney
cast member but yeah so I were like
attractions the rides let's say like
Disney or like Universal can't be you
and ask like hey we need a centerpiece
for like an attraction or a land or
whatever you know based on the existing
property like if you could do like a
Marvel building or attraction or Die
Hard movie attraction thing what would
it be like what would you dislike to see
alright great number one great question
hell yeah number two and it's anything
that Disney owns which now includes all
the anything you want anything Golden
Girls attraction just you go through the
house whatever you want oh [ __ ] alright
I got one go I got one Dark Crystal Dark
Crystal
I think I think there's a there's a ton
of [ __ ] juice in that IP and I think
you could absolutely make some scary
awesome wonderful rollercoasters and
haunted houses and eateries maybe I
don't know but I think getting to see
[ __ ] sketches walking around the
parking [ __ ] would be kind of amazing
like that guy would you like a job sir
at my imaginary Park which will never
exist but you can be the one guy who
works at it I don't [ __ ] I can go if you
want to buy some time
I think it'd be cool like have like a
Baxter building or EQ to like walk
through it or like you know Monsters Inc
or transformers or like sick in a car
like maybe it because like f her be like
narrating your journey through Reed
Richards lab and all the stuffs going on
have you come early the robot yeah
Herbie the robot our child yeah another
one go strange brew sounds cold a
strange brew ride my strange fruit
[ __ ] like you know you got a what
Conda you got a never-never-land you go
- it's a small world you got a [ __ ]
the Elsinore brewery or Canada or Canada
Canada Italy Canadian we would call it I
mean they're doing the Star Wars thing
now right and apparently it's like
immersive it's not just like hey come to
Star Wars land the Disney World one
that's gonna have like a hotel that
connects to the land yes where once
you're inside there are no windows it's
all screens it's like space and ships
and [ __ ] like that you put on robes if
you go to the like the where like it's
they give you different clothes to wear
it becomes like this immersive cosplay
experience if you go into the souvenir
stores it's not like Disneyland Star
Wars or Disney World Star Wars it's
themed to that world that they're
creating sounds [ __ ] impressive the
[ __ ] I look forward to it sounds
expensive
that's in a spot - sounds like they're
gonna get a lot more of my money
what would I like to do that immersive
the Degrassi experience you know you
enter high school and immediately you
start cutting yourself drinketh there
getting or getting [ __ ] for
bracelets somebody gets shot yeah I
think that'd be pretty hot man the
Degrassi experience okay I mean that
herb I mean I would I might do Snoopy
like peanuts were see alright but I
think I'm the only one that gives a [ __ ]
about that anymore I don't think anybody
would be like Oh [ __ ] yeah man the Red
Baron I would you know those people be
like that's old man [ __ ] old man if I
get Willy Wonka oh that's good real
[ __ ] good let's do that whole Willy
Wonka mercy parent it's a choco River
and you're gonna kill children halfway
through yeah [ __ ] a you know what
that's a great question that deserves
tickets give it up for Malaysia Ellen
happy anniversary a pleasure
JC three more people three more sets of
questions take us there
Joanne how you doing how are you what's
your name Justin Justin so real quick my
clerks thing that I just want to thank
you for marriage was never really my
thing and I was going through the
reasons why you know I should or
shouldn't get married but it came down
to it is my wife brings me lasagna I try
to tell her that she's like wait you
mean like really do I bring you lasagna
I'm like no not figuratively yeah you're
not not literally just figured I don't
like ricotta cheese baby I'm sorry but
my wife at one point we were making
clerks too and we were on the lab
tonight of shooting at quick stuff and
she showed up with lasagna and I was
like oh man like you watched the movie
once thank you so no yeah now I have a
wife and a kid and it's it's it's awful
but a question so one of the books that
got me back into comics was pax romana
okay and I read what in 2014 sci-fi
picked it up and nothing has happened to
it so I was wondering if you guys have
heard anything a about Pax Romana as a
series when I close that book I'm like
that is a TV show that is gonna be a
dope TV show but nothing's happened but
if it does get happen who would you like
to see either right direct or showrunner
I'm familiar with this ice planet for
those of us that are well Justin can
probably do it better than anybody
because I remember that Hickman wrote
the book and I remember it was some kind
of like altar in the history where the
Roman Empire never fell right basically
the Catholic Church becomes irrelevant
in the present day and they but they
discover time travel and so they send an
army back to the time of Constantine to
ensure the rise of Catholicism but they
have spoiler a different like the guys
who run it have a different idea and
their whole thing is just to advance
humanity like accelerate humanity and
this is super heavy trippy experience
that's a well soul man I'm like that
sounds fun no it's honestly it's one of
the best books I've read holy [ __ ] I
don't know what happened to it but
knowing Hollywood the way I know
Hollywood most things don't happen
actually you know I mean the the way it
ends up working is you know a TV network
will decide hey all right its
development season we had our last year
we had our awesome shows we cancelled a
bunch we picked up a few what's the new
things for next year and they will buy
between 70 and 100
properties either scripts or pitches or
whatever and then they will deliver
scripts on those things of those 70 to
100 they will greenlight 15 pilots that
they will actually shoot and then of
those 15 they will shoot they will pick
up five give or take like that's that's
the [ __ ] Hunger Games of TV so most
things don't happen you know I'm sure
Jonathan Hickman got paid and probably
paid very well if I would wanted to see
anybody run that shot when him to run it
because I think he knows that world
better than anybody and I think he's
he's probably at the point in his comics
career when he like Brubaker could be
like you know what i if I'm gonna slide
over into TV I need to be running this
[ __ ] like a tremendous running deadly
class for sci-fi as for who would star I
don't know the book well enough to say
anybody but aegis album because that's
what I always say so and I'm sure it
doesn't make any sense but [ __ ] it it
was over that I I can't comment cuz I
haven't seen it but you [ __ ] sold me
on the on the book how long was it oh
god it was a 5/5 issues its miniseries
yeah who drew I think he did it himself
he has drawn before I think it I want to
say there was an Italian guy what is it
called Pax Romana Nick Patara or
somebody like that it was his second
series I think it was on image image
book yep [ __ ] man you just sold me some
comics man that's great question get it
up for me what's a bigot
okay we got somebody else a good girl
right Oh what's your name my friend
tomorrow ratinho tomorrow everyone give
it up for tomorrow today what do you got
for us tomorrow um so let's see sorry I
got nervous no worries you can face the
wall if that helps okay I can be weird
for the rest of us you look like the guy
at the end of [ __ ] Blair Witch
Project but yeah I'm good so one thing I
wanted to say and you missed a lot of
this conversation earlier I miss most
conversations was that tonight I walked
in and it was mostly dudes which I
expected but we talked so you guys
talked so much about the contributions
of women recently in comics in want you
know monstrous and you know female
directors and you know Awards got the
Eisner Award all this stuff right and
the first transgender character like all
this stuff that's yet in superhero so
what I want to ask you and then I'm also
looking around so it's mostly dudes it's
also mostly white dudes from Italy and
we have you know we got black jersey
familiar with it black panther we've got
things changing in that world you know I
do see it coming in it's changing and
we're seeing more representation but the
butts and seats are still mostly white
dudes so what do you see how do you see
that changing and how do you see your
contribution to that and awareness to
that and how do you you know how does
this demographic begin to evolve I don't
know what did you just raise your hands
I was like I believe pernil wants to
take this one I mean having her here
tonight was so [ __ ] badass
I mean hurt for myself I think you know
a it changes when people hire me like
almost immediately and and the idea that
there are other people liking me out
there you know there are other people
who grew up loving this [ __ ] and other
people grew up breathing this stuff who
would kill to want to make this stuff
you know I remember there was there was
some interview with some oh man I think
it was it was actually David Letterman
on his show whose interview Tina Fey and
he seemed to mystified that women wanted
to write comedy and it's like yeah but
no gave which did if they told him it's
like we've always wanted to do what you
just didn't care you know I think some
of it has to be the idea that we
understand that the audience is changing
that the world is changing that
everybody has a story to tell and we've
heard lots and lots and lots and lots of
the same story and so invite somebody
new to tell a story and you know what
happens when you do that
lots and lots and lots of people show up
you know I mean if you don't get a black
panther you don't get a Wonder Woman you
don't get stuff like this you don't get
Fast and the Furious if people didn't
have some back brain awareness that they
weren't getting that you know that they
weren't being served you know that
that's a that's a fancy Hollywood that's
an underserved audience you're just not
making sure for them they're there for
they'll buy it if you give it to them
and realizing that as the audience
changes the people make the content have
to change the people in seats like in
houses like this are going to change you
know in it's incremental
it's always incremental Hollywood is the
slowest [ __ ] thing in the world but
it's starting and it's happening and
there are a lot of white guys here [ __ ]
started look like a Klan rally in here I
don't really notice I always kind of
just look it comes out I guess I get I
really don't have anything to say
because I'm part of the problem
well I like your answer keep going but
and also like one of the funny things
that happened when we started to his
podcast
yeah is it was audio first yes for the
first like year and a half and family
only and and I'm not sure if you can
tell but I have a somewhat elusive
accent it does nothing that he could be
a man or a woman
yes his voice is very supple in that it
does not betray any ethnicity nor does
my name betray any ethnicity so if you
just came to this podcast just [ __ ]
blind and you listen to it you weren't
you probably thought I was a white guy
which is fine it's how I help get my mom
we have her like utilities turn back on
put your right voice on this is Mark
Barnard it hello
I'm very upset I would like my
electricity back please please and thank
you but then we put cameras up and and
suddenly there were people who had been
listening for a long time who had never
really even thought for a second that I
might not be like them because Kevin's
audience it's wonderful they're like
salted the other amazing people but
they're also somewhat indicative of this
room it looks like a Thor comic book
which is also totally fine like you like
what you like you love what you love but
suddenly we began having a conversation
that I don't think much of that audience
had ever had before
and we're talking about things like
representation things like diversity
things like what it means to see
yourself on screen and by and large like
you know 99 times out of 100 this
audience was down to have that
conversation and realized I never
thought of it that way I never looked at
it that way and just the the prying open
of that little bit of reality to some
people was fundamentally made it all
worthwhile wasn't he suddenly he's like
you know what [ __ ] how goes he black
panther you know I'd maybe I wouldn't
before but I mean I totally was gonna
but now I'm like open to it anyway I
hadn't been because I get to talk about
what it means to me in the same way that
the stuff they saw when they were kids
meant something today
and I think being able to have these
conversations being able to speak openly
and candidly with people from different
backgrounds and from different
ethnicities and who have raised
different ways only makes the world
better you know and I think that the
more we can have these conversations the
more it becomes less weird when you come
into a room where you don't maybe see
yourself but you understand that they
know you a little bit because somebody
else went and talked to them about a
[ __ ] superhero movie yeah
one thing about representation I have to
say Kevin thank you as a young bisexual
woman and I know you got some feedback
and yeah opposite direction about it but
chasing amy was actually really
important to me to see representation if
somebody bisexual on screen was so a
life affirming for me and super [ __ ]
positive and I'm really grateful for
that movie thank you so much for that
this is this I mean I have no really I'm
not supposed to be speaking about
representation but this is what I can
say about representation that's the only
reason I'm here nowadays representation
means diversity people that don't look
like me when I was younger I made clerks
because I wanted to be represented I
went to movies and I never saw myself
like I enjoyed them but I never saw me
and my friends up there my world
reflected in stuff so one of the reasons
in Megan clerk so I wanted to make
clerks was I just wanted to see I mean
my friends not us personally but our
world up there I wanted to look up and
see something that was achingly familiar
to me and I did and and so it's weird
you know for a middle-aged white guy to
talk about representation but there was
a time I wasn't represented
now everybody represents me you know now
they've embraced geek community now that
if I could talk about comic books and
all that [ __ ] I was talking about but
that's nice now is the conversation
about representation is going to folks
that like you know I was not saying I
was the last of my [ __ ] breed but
it's like I was a there was a time it's
tough to remember now but there was a
time where people then talked about
[ __ ] publicly he [ __ ] talked about
comic books a pod cat well they didn't
even exist but the idea that people
would talk seriously about you know
ridiculous throwaway junk culture and
stuff that was a world that like I just
wanted to show the world that I lived in
where all we did was discuss this [ __ ]
on a regular basis as if it were the
Pentagon Papers this was more important
than [ __ ] politics the news [ __ ]
anything it was like this was the real
mana of life and and there are moments
when I feel like you know this sounds
goofy and I'm not just saying it because
we do the podcast but like I've been
doing my [ __ ] for 25 years and like
there are moments where I'm like you
should just step aside so that other
people can do their [ __ ] because at the
end of the day their shits always going
to be more interesting than my [ __ ]
because I've been doing my [ __ ] for a
minute and stuff but they're a bunch of
voices out there that I've had never had
a bite at that Apple and stuff so you
know for a while I I thought about like
just stepping away cuz I you know it's
weird nobody ever tells you what to do
in your with this job like when it's
supposed to end like most other jobs
there's a retirement age or like you
know [ __ ] you get a gold watch or
some [ __ ] but this is you're left to
your own devices like you jump out
anytime you want unless they [ __ ]
throw you out on your ass or something
like that
so there are moments where I'm like
maybe I should segue away but then
there's also an opportunity I got where
if I do get something like series now I
could bring other people in and other
people that don't look or more
importantly think like me that's that's
where you're gonna get like really
interesting [ __ ] storylines and stuff
so you know it's again weird to talk
about but I wanted to see me in my world
now other people are doing the same
thing if you look up on a screen or you
open a comic book or watch TV or you
just and you don't see yourself fill
fill that hole if you find a hole fill
it sounds dirtier than I mean it but
like okay if there's a if there's a hole
and there's a nap
that's an opportunity like I'm only
standing here before you 25 years after
that [ __ ] clerks nonsense because
there wasn't a clerks prior to that
there's nothing out there like what you
can bring to the party as a voice that
hasn't been heard a thousand times
before and that goes for everyone
listening at home and stuff like that
so if you feel that absence it begins
with you that's how I started I was like
well nobody's gonna make a movie about
the [ __ ] I find funny unless I make it
myself so if you see a hole like best
opportunity for you personally and
career-wise if you're the one that moves
toward it to be like okay here's me I'm
gonna represent me that was a great
[ __ ] question great discussion give
it up for LA what are these you do
acupuncture
grandpa poacher all right bands called
cramp Stein but ya know I do it's true
yeah but I do acupuncture here locally
and I wanted to offer you and Mark and
Jay to come in and for some free
treatments some cupping whatever cuz I
was really concerned about wouldn't you
when you had your thing and I want you
guys to all have some chill time so
you're more than welcome to come and
have someone on the house give it up for
a ladies and gentlemen I have Leah
tomorrow I might do that
actually I've always been like I did
Acts Parker once with somebody who
sucked at it and I would imagine you're
good I do like a good cupping now what
is you've done cupping that when you
walk up to a dude and you're like makes
it feel better and sure you know like I
feel like a hundred bucks justified
testify which is where that came from
did it really yeah but explain testify
in testicle have the exact same route
which is back in ancient Rome when you
would have to tell the truth they would
literally hold on to your balls to see
if you're alive
are you [ __ ] race where the god why
did we move away that why did we move
away from that to like put your hand on
this Bible and pray because because one
of them gets the real true real ABS
because you know body temperature
changes with your balls and it also
changes when you lie and so if your body
temperature rises your balls hang
differently if you're lying how do you
know this just looked it up one day the
same way you know random [ __ ] about
Switzerland I guess yeah well I know
where I'm [ __ ] about Switzerland because
I experienced it did you grab someone's
balls I don't understand
you know you grab you get grabbed you
tell the truth you lie it's all the same
thing [ __ ] that should be the [ __ ]
standard man where the like do you swear
to tell the truth the whole truth
nothing but truth so help you God [ __ ]
yes
and the whole testimony you're just
[ __ ]
hold on there man and [ __ ] and the
judge could be like I don't know if I
agree with that and they go a little
tighter cigar doors a Wednesday all
right we got one set of tickets left and
we got my man sitting here in a [ __ ]
beautiful 66 Batman shirt what's your
name my friend Dave give it up for Dave
everybody testified Dave all Batman
second I have a question about Batman so
oh my god that's so rare on this show
nothing do you never get to talk about
Batman that's awesome so I grew up
watching uh the Fox Batman
yes 66 but so the first three seasons of
Batman they had a distinct style which I
really loved and then they went to
season four and it looked like
Superman's cartoon which I didn't really
care for right but I know you spoke with
Bruce Timm and Paul Dini mr. your
podcast from way back when did they say
why why they might have changed the
animation yes Bruce Timm got bored and
not in a shitty like I'm bored claudus
like it just like he's an artist and he
was bored with his style artists change
all the time in comics you tend to draw
the character on model and stuff like
that they created an entirely new look
with that Batman animated series but
rather than rest on the laurels couple
years in he was like I've always hated
the Joker's eyes so I would always
always wanted to do big black pupils for
him so it chiefly came from from Bruce
kind of going in and being like I want
to redesign some of these characters
make it more fun for him as an artist I
guess if it's fun for him maybe it
translates in the show but some people
didn't go with the designs 100% like a
lot of people like divided on the
animated Joker based on whether he's got
just the big black coal eyes or you know
the round irises with pupils as well but
that was the story I heard you I have no
evidence to contrary that sure justify
yeah honestly it came down to like style
choice at the end of the day and and you
know you got to grant them that right
like those cats were revolutionary when
they introduced the the Batman the
Animated Series style it took a lot to
push that through in the first place
where they were like no we're gonna make
it look like the old Max Fleischer
Superman cartoons to begin with and
stuff so I'm sure you know folks at
Warner Brothers were like can it can it
be less edgy and more traditional or
something and then once they had some
success under their belts and they'd won
some awards I think Bruce was just like
alright let me do this the way I really
want to do it and stuff and kind of went
in there and redesign so wait where were
you on the redesigns you didn't dig it I
liked the first three years and then
because of your podcast I went in a met
Kevin Conroy at Stan Lee's comic-con
last year take a picture with him but
again your your podcast with him is the
only one that I save I just the one that
you actually hold on to right
yeah this story is really compelling but
also it's like when you listen to that
episode of the show it's like literally
me interviewing Batman the whole time
because you're like oh my god that's the
voice of Batman and [ __ ] that was the
episode I think where I was like can you
tell me I did the right thing and the
Batman voice and he was like Kevin
you've done the right thing you know
sometimes still play that when I go to
sleep at night that was a great question
you get tickets ladies and out of my
well done
pleasures oh my God we're out of tickets
that means we're out of questions and
stuff like that and that means we are at
the show's end have you had a good time
just ladies John
I want to thank pernil for coming on and
talking and stuff give it up for Emil
and I want to think thank the great Eric
Roscoe for pitch hitting for mark here
man
thank you but there is no fat man on
Batman as we know it without the man to
my left give it up for Captain Castle
Rock Marc Bernard gentleman we are gonna
be down next week because I'm in New
Jersey I guess you haven't you got a
birthday I have a birthday coming up I'm
about to turn 48 and I'm gonna do it on
the East Coast where I was born and
stuff so but we'll be back probably the
week after that I checked the website
I'm sure JC will put something up in the
meantime thank you for being here
tonight ladies gentlemen do not forget
when you leave here walk down a few
blocks see Quentin's movie and tell him
Kevin sent you that is fat man on Batman
for this week I'm Kevin Smith I am mark
lunardon tune in next time same bat-time
same bat-channel SModcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
[Applause]
[Music]
you